SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR ON STATE
ADMINISTRATION.
TODAY.
OKAY FORCE AGAIN STARTED SO
PLEASE QUIET DOWN.
TABLE DISCUSS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSALS FOR
VARIOUS LABOR RELATED
DEPARTMENTS.
CURRY TO HAVE A QUORUM SCHOOL
STARS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
IN THE FIRST I'M GONNA HERE IS
FROM OUR I'M TO BE HEARD AND
ITEM NUMBER -- ONE LETTERS
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL BUREAU
WORKPLACE CONDUCT UNIT
.
PLEASE WE GET OKAY.
I'M WE'RE HERE WITH RESPECT TO
THE WORKPLACE CONDUCT UNIT OF
THIS BUDGET CYCLE WERE ASKING
FOR ONE POINT SIX MILLION. NINE
HUNDRED ONE FOUR SIX I'M.
A SUCKER TO A I'M SORRY -- I'VE
SIGNED WE KNOW WHO YOU ARE BUT
COMMUNITIES YOURSELF FOR SURE
I'M THE FOCUS WHAT I AM LAWYER
VINE OFFICE LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL
I HAVE WITH ME JULIE JOHNSON WHO
IS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
WORKPLACE CONDUCT UNIT.
AND KRISTEN OR WHO'S THE CHIEF
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL BUREAU.
SO THE UNIT WAS ESTABLISHED LAST
YEAR -- WITH THE BUDGET APART
ITEM APPROPRIATION TO GET US UP
AND RUNNING IN THIS YEAR WERE
ASKING -- FOR ONE MILLION SIX
HUNDRED NINETY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR THE ON GOING ON
OPERATIONS OF THE WORKPLACE
CONDUCT UNIT THAT INCLUDES OUR
STAFFING WITH. TO INVESTIGATOR
WHO'S OUR ATTORNEYS ARE DIRECTOR
AND WON PARALEGAL AND THEN OUR
ON GOING RENT.
AND IT SERVICES FOR THE UNIT
PLUS THE FIVE PANELISTS WHO ARE
UNDER CONTRACT WITH THE UNIT --
TO THEY MAKE UP THE INDEPENDENT
PANEL THAT WILL HEAR VARIOUS
INVESTIGATIONS AND MAKE
RECOMMENDED FINDINGS OF
VIOLATIONS AND RECOMMENDED
DISCIPLINE.
IN HARASSMENT RELATED MATTERS.
THANK YOU FINANCE.
NOTHING FURTHER TO ADD.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SOMEONE.
THANK YOU -- I REQUEST FOR
DIRECTOR JOHNSON JUST ASSUME THE
ROLE OF RUNNING THE WORKPLACE
CONDUCT UNIT.
THIS BUDGET REQUEST REFLECTS
ASSUMPTIONS.
ABOUT THE WORTH OF THE UNIT THAT
WERE SET BEFORE YOU SEEM TO ROLE.
DO THAT LEVEL OF REFERRALS
INVESTIGATION YOU HAVE SEEN SO
FAR -- LINE OF THE EXPECTATIONS
THAT YOU WERE SET.
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL IS CRAFTED.
I THINK THAT THEY ARE A LITTLE
BIT HIGHER THAN THEY THAN WAS
ORIGINALLY PROJECTED WHICH IS
WHY WE ARE.
LOOKING TO POTENTIALLY HIRE
SOMEONE IN THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR --
BUT OTHERWISE I THINK WITH THAT
ADDITIONAL POSITION THAT THEY
SHOULD BE IN LINE WITH.
THE EXPECTATIONS.
GIVE US A SENSE OF THE SIZE AND
SCOPE OF THE WORK WHICH IS SEEN
TO THIS DAY.
SURE.
WE HAVE ABOUT. TO DATE WE HAVE.
SIXTY THREE COMPLAINTS THAT
WE'VE RECEIVED.
AND WE'VE BEEN OPEN SINCE
FEBRUARY ONE SO IT THAT THAT
AVERAGE IS A LITTLE BIT MORE
THAN ONE PER DAY.
DO YOU EXPECT THAT LEVEL OF WORK
TO GROW OR SHRINK IN THE COMING
MONTHS -- I I BELIEVE THAT IT
WILL PROBABLY GO DOWN SLIGHTY
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT WE WERE
NEW AND PEOPLE WERE EXPECTING TO
BE ABLE TO MAKE THESE COMPLAINTS.
IN ADDITION A WE'VE BEEN
TRAINING AS YOU'RE AWARE THAT
MISTER CHAIRMAN WE'VE BEEN
TRAINING.
OF THE MEMBERS AND THE EMPLOYEES
SO THAT I THINK.
MANY PEOPLE HAVE -- COME FORWARD
BECAUSE OF THAT THE TRAINING
THAT WE HAVE BEEN PROVIDING
[inaudible]
THE COMMENTS.
OKAY THIS PLAN WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC COMMENTS.
OKAY WE MAKE SURE THIS WORKPLACE
CONDUCT UNIT HAS RESOURCES IT
NEEDS TO CONDUCT ITS WORK IN A
TIMELY AND THOROUGH MANNER --
PLEASE RETURN TO US EXCUSE ME
PLEASE RETURN TO US THE RESOURCE
PROVIDER NOT SUFFICIENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THIS WILL THIS NUMBER TO THE
PART OF INDUSTRIALIZATION.
DOMESTIC WORKER RIGHTS EDUCATION
AND OUTREACH
.
GOVERNOR.
WE GET TO START WONDERFUL YES
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR COOPER AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HAVING
US HERE TODAY.
MY NAME IS LINDSAY EMI HONG I AM
THE CALIFORNIA.
DIRECTOR FOR HAND IN HAND THE
DOMESTIC EMPLOYERS NETWORK WE
ARE A NATIONAL NETWORK OF
EMPLOYERS OF NANNIES HOUSE
CLEANERS AND HOME CARE WORKERS.
THAT USE ORGANIZING EDUCATION.
TO ADVANCE DIGNIFY WORKING
CONDITIONS THAT BENEFIT WORKER
AN EMPLOYER LIKE.
I'M ALSO A MOTHER AND I HIRED A
NANNY FOR ALMOST FIVE YEARS.
JESSICA HELPED ME RAISE MY SONS
SHE TAUGHT ME A LOT ABOUT
PARENTING.
SHE HELPED TAKE CARE OF THEM
ALMOST FIVE DAYS A WEEK.
ALLOW ME TO CONTINUE MY CAREER I
WILL BE FOREVER GRATEFUL TO HER.
I AM HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BUDGET ASK OF FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO CREATE THE DOMESTIC
WORKER RIGHTS EDUCATION OUTREACH
PROGRAM.
WITHIN THE DIVISION OF LABOR
STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT.
THIS PROGRAM WOULD BENEFIT BOTH
THE THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOMESTIC WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA
BUT ALSO THE OVER TWO MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS THAT RELY ON THEIR
LABOR AND SERVICES.
AND THESE NUMBERS ARE EXPECTED
TO GROW GIVEN THE UNPRECEDENTED
GROWTH IN THE NUMBER OF SENIORS
NEEDING IN HOME CARE.
DOMESTIC EMPLOYERS ARE UNLIKE
ANY OTHER KIND OF EMPLOYER.
ANYONE CAN BECOME A DOMESTIC
EMPLOYER TOMORROW A CALIFORNIAN
COULD REALIZE THE NEED TO HIRE A
NANNY HOUSE CLEANER OR HOME CARE
ATTENDANT.
AND COULD DO SO WITHOUT HAVING
ANY PRIOR KNOWLEDGE OF THEIR
EMPLOYER RESPONSIBILITIES.
MANY OF US DO NOT THINK OF
OURSELVES AS EMPLOYERS BECAUSE
THE WORK HAPPENS IN THE INTIMACY
OF OUR HOMES.
AND MANY OF US BECOMING PLAYERS
IN THE MIDST OF A MAJOR LIFE
CHANGE AND SOMETIMES AN
EMERGENCY LIKE WHEN AN AGING
PARENT FALLS.
AND SUDDENLY NEEDS HELP WITH
ACTIVITIES OF DAILY LIVING.
AT HAND IN HAND I MEET.
NEW PARENTS WHO ARE DESPERATE TO
FIND QUALITY CHILD CARE FOR
THEIR BABIES.
AS WELL AS HOUSE CLEANER IN HOME
CARE EMPLOYERS.
WHO ARE HOPING TO ESTABLISH
MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL WORKING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE PEOPLE
THEY EMPLOY?
GET THE OFTEN SIMPLY DO NOT KNOW
WHERE TO START. FOR THIS REASON
I AM EXCITED ABOUT THE DOMESTIC
WORKER RIGHTS EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH PROGRAM.
IT WOULD PROVIDE NECESSARY
TRAINING TO BOTH DOMESTIC
WORKERS AND DOMESTIC EMPLOYERS
ON IMPORTANT LABOR PROTECTIONS
SUCH AS MINIMUM WAGE.
SICK LEAVE RECORDKEEPING AND
RETALIATION.
IT WOULD ALSO INCLUDE
INFORMATION ABOUT OVERTIME PAY
WHICH WAS A RIGHT THAT WAS
RECENTLY.
MADE PERMANENT WITH THE PASSAGE
OF THE TWENTY SIXTEEN CALIFORNIA
DOMESTIC WORKER.
BILL OF RIGHTS.
IT WAS FIRST ESTABLISHED IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN WITH A. B..
TWO FOUR ONE IT IS CONCERNING
THAT IN A STATEWIDE STUDY
CONDUCTED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE
UCLA LABOR CENTER FOUND THAT
ONLY ABOUT ONE IN EVERY FOUR
DOMESTIC EMPLOYERS KNEW ABOUT
THIS NEW LAW. FOR BECOMING
EMPLOYERS EVERY DAY WITHOUT ANY
UNDERSTANDING OF IT.
SO LET'S FIND THE DOMESTIC
WORKER RIGHTS EDUCATION OUTREACH
PROGRAM TO CHANGE THAT.
I NOW WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE
TERRY VS IN YOUR OF THE FILIPINO
WORKER CENTER THANK YOU.
HI THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
TERRY VS IN YOUR AND I'M A
WORKER LE LATER FROM THE BILL
BEEN WORK A CENTURY.
I WORK AS A FULL TIME CARE GIVER
FOR SENIOR CLIENT AND HIS WIFE
AND THEIR FAMILY HOME.
I WORKING SHIFT BETWEEN TWELVE
AND TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY AND
SUPPORT MY CLIENTS IN ALL OF HIS.
ACTIVITIES DAILY NEEDS I PREPARE
MY CLIENTS IN WIFE MEALS.
AND I BRING MY CLIENTS THESE
DOCTORS APPOINTMENTS.
AND I SEE HIM TAKING HIS
MEDICATION I ALSO ASSIST HIM
WITH ALL THESE ART PROJECT AND
HIS DAILY ACTIVITIES.
HIS WIFE AND HIS DAUGHTER AND
SON ALSO I NEED TO RESPOND TO
THEIR NEEDS AS WELL I'M MORE
THAN A CARE GIVER.
I'M ALSO FOUND YET TENDON AS
SECRETARY AND A COOK.
MY WORK IS IMPORTANT.
AND VALUABLE TO THE FAMILY AND
I'M HERE TODAY TO ENSURE THAT MY
JOB AS A DOMESTIC WORKER.
A PROFESSION THAT IS HELD BY A
MAJORITY OF IMMIGRANT WOMEN
RECEIVE THE DIGNITY AND RESPECT
IT DESERVES.
BEFORE I JOINED A PPO ACRE
CENTER I WORKED FOR FIVE YEARS.
AS THE CARE GIVER I WAS NOT
AWARE THAT DOMESTIC WORKERS.
HAD ANY LABOR PROTECTION AT ALL
BECAUSE OUR WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
INFORMAL AND INTIMATE.
WORKPLACE OF SOMEONE'S PRIVATE
HOME.
I WORK FOR FAMILIES TO LIVE IN
CARE GIVER FOR TWENTY FOUR HOURS
A DAY I RECEIVED OVER TIME NO
OVERTIME PAY.
NO PAID TIME OFF AND SICKLY OF I
KNEW IN MY HEART THAT THERE WAS
SOMETHING WRONG.
WITH THAT PICTURE BUT I DIDN'T
KNOW THAT I HAD LABOR RIGHTS AND
PROTECTION I FELT TRAPPED I WAS
ALONE IN MY EMPLOYERS HOME.
AND I DIDN'T KNOW WHERE TO GO TO
FIND RESOURCES OF WHAT STEPS TO
TAKE TO NAVIGATE MY SITUATION.
I ESPECIALLY THOUGHT I COULD NOT
DO ANYTHING ABOUT MY SITUATION
BECAUSE I WITH AND UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS.
AT THAT TIME I FEARED BEING
DEPORTED.
AND I FEARED LOSING MY ONLY
SOURCE OF INCOME FOR MYSELF AND
FOR MY FAMILY.
JUST LIKE ME THE MAJORITY OF
DOMESTIC WORKER WHETHER DAY YOU
ARE A HOUSE CLEANER NANNIES OR
HOME CARE.
WORKER ATTENDANT DO NOT KNOW OUR
RIGHTS OR WHAT WE CAN DO IF OUR
RIGHTS HAVE BEEN VIOLATED.
AND AS MEANS A FAD.
OUR EMPLOYERS DO NOT KNOW THE
LAWS OR DO REFUSE TO BELIEVE
THAT THE LABOR LAWS EVEN MINIMUM
WAGE ACTUALLY.
APPLY INSIDE THEIR HOMES.
I'M EITHER GETTING FOR THE
DOMESTIC WORKERS RIGHT EDUCATION
AND OUTREACH PROGRAM SO THAT OUR
RIGHTS ARE UNDERSTOOD BY BOTH
WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS.
AND SO THAT THOSE RIGHTS ARE
ACTUALLY FUNCTION TO PROTECT US
IN OUR DAILY.
LIVES THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU [inaudible]
WE ARE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CHAIR COOPER ANOTHER
MEMBERS MY NAME IS VICTORIA HAAS
SEED I'M THE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS -- SUBJECT
TO LAST YEAR'S BUDGET LANGUAGE
WE ARE PREPARING A STUDY TO
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE ON THE
DOMESTIC WORKER INDUSTRY.
THAT WILL INCLUDE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON ACTIONS TAKE
FORWARD AS WELL AS AN OVERVIEW
OF THE INDUSTRY AS IT STANDS
TODAY.
ALL PROVIDE SOME OF A
PRELIMINARY REPORT -- FOR THE
COMMITTEE HERE TODAY THAT -- IN
THE FULL REPORT WILL BE LATER
THIS SUMMER.
SO FOR AN OVERVIEW.
THE STATE OF THE INDUSTRY THE
NUMBER OF CALIFORNIANS AGE SIXTY
FIVE AND OLDER IS EXPECTED TO
NEARLY DOUBLE AND REACH ALMOST
NINE MILLION BY.
TWENTY THIRTY THIS WILL REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL CARE GIVERS.
WHAT CHILD CARE WORKER
EMPLOYMENT IS GROWING SLOWLY AND
THE NUMBER OF HOME HEALTH AIDES
HAS RECENTLY SHRUNK?
THE RANKS OF PERSONAL KERRY'S IN
CALIFORNIA HAS RISEN
DRAMATICALLY TO OVER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND IS EXPECTED TO
CONTINUE TO RISE BY ALMOST 35% A
YEAR.
THROUGH.
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR ACCORDING TO
CALIFORNIA'S EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT THERE ARE
ABOUT -- FIVE TO SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND FORMAL DIRECT CARE
GIVERS AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN OF
FROM TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND OR
HOME HEALTH AIDES.
AS WE LOOK TO THE DATA THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE CONDUCTED
A STATEWIDE REVIEW OF ALL CLAIMS
RECEIVE IN. 201-620-1720
EIGHTEEN AND CLAIMS THROUGH MID
FEBRUARY TWENTY NINETEEN FOR THE
PURPOSES OF THIS STUDY.
THAT WERE ATTRIBUTED TO DOMESTIC
WORKERS AND MORE SPECIFICALLY
PERSONAL ATTENDANTS WERE
DOCUMENTED AS A TYPE OF WORK
MEETING THE DEFINITION OF
PERSONAL ATTENDANT PER THE LABOR
CODE.
BEFORE GETTING INTO THE
PRELIMINARY FINDINGS FROM THAT
REVIEW.
I DO URGE CAUTION WHEN LOOKING
AT THE DATA IS THERE ARE SEVERAL --
SEVERAL FACTORS TO CONSIDER.
IN TERMS OF BARRIERS -- TO
UNDERSTANDING THAT UNDERSTANDING
THE INDUSTRY BETTER AND ALSO
BARRIERS TO GREATER ENFORCEMENT.
AND THE CLOUD RECOMMENDATIONS.
THEIR LOGISTICAL AND
JURISDICTIONAL BARRIERS FOR
ENFORCEMENT ONE IS EMPLOYER
CLIENTS HOME IS THE PLACE OF
EMPLOYMENT WHICH THE
NONTRADITIONAL WORKPLACE.
OUR FIELD ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
TYPICALLY WOULD NOT ENTER
CLIENTS HOME FOR AN
INVESTIGATION BUT WOULD INSTEAD
SET UP WHAT'S KNOWN AS IN ORDER
TO APPEAR.
MOST OF THE CLAIMS RECEIVED OR
THROUGH OUR WAGE CLAIM PROCESS
WHICH REQUIRES THE WORKER
THEMSELVES TO COME FORWARD.
THERE COULD BE FEAR OF THE LOSS
OF JOB IN OR BENEFITS SUCH AS
RUMOR BOARD IF COMING FORWARD.
THERE'S ALSO SOME LEGAL
COMPLEXITY GIVEN THE CHANGING
STATE THE LAW WHICH I WILL TOUCH
ON IN A MOMENT.
STATE FEDERAL CASE LAW IMPACT
THIS GROUP OF WORKERS AND THE
EMPLOYERS AND DOES NEED TO BE
CLARIFIED.
SINCE PASSAGE OF THE DOMESTIC
WORKERS BILL OF RIGHTS OVER TIME
HERE IT'S OF CALIFORNIA'S
PERSONAL ATTENDANTS HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY.
ONE A TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT CASE
MINEOLA VERSUS CPS SECURITY
SOLUTIONS.
WHICH CONCERNED COMPATIBILITY OF
ON CALL AND SLEEP TIME.
THE FEDERAL HOME CARE FINAL RULE
SHORTLY THEREAFTER AND THERE
HAVE BEEN NUMEROUS OTHER LABOR
LAWS THAT HAVE IMPACTED THIS
POPULATION AND AFFECTED THIS
INDUSTRY IN TERMS OF INCREASING
LOCAL AND STATE MINIMUM WAGE.
WITH THAT BEING SAID.
THESE WERE THE FINDINGS FROM
THAT CLAIM REVIEW FROM TWENTY
SIXTEEN TO MID FEBRUARY.
TWENTY NINETEEN OVER 90% OF
CLAIMANTS REPORTED THAT THEY
WERE CARE GIVERS INCLUDING
DOMESTIC WORKERS PERSONAL DIRECT
CARE HOME CARE AT CETERA.
AND AMONG THESE 2% SPECIFIED
ELDER CARE.
IN AN EQUAL PERCENTAGE 2%
INDICATE THAT THEY PROVIDE
TWENTY FOUR HOUR OR LIVE IN CARE.
NANNIES CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
COMPRISE 6%.
ONLY 3% DESCRIBED THEIR TYPE OF
WORK SPECIFICALLY AS PERSONAL
ATTENDANTS.
BETWEEN TWENTY SIXTEEN TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THERE WAS AN OVERALL
STEADY INCREASE OF THE NUMBER OF
WAGE CLAIMS FILED WITH THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE.
IN TOTAL ROUGHLY EIGHT HUNDRED
CLAIMS DURING THAT TIME PERIOD
WITH A HIGHER CONCENTRATION IN
THE GREATER EL áREA AND THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA CORRESPONDING
WITH LARGER POPULATION CENTERS
IN THE STATE.
WE DO CAUTION AGAIN THAT THE
LIMITED NUMBER SUGGEST THAT
FINDINGS SHOULD BE INTERPRETED
WITH CAUTION AND ARE NOT
NECESSARILY.
GENERAL BE ABLE TO BE
GENERALIZED TO ALL DOMESTIC
WORKERS.
WORKERS REPORT AN AVERAGE WAGE
OF THIRTEEN DOLLARS AND SIXTY
FOUR CENTS AN HOUR AND THE
MEDIAN WAS ELEVEN DOLLARS AND
FIFTY CENTS AN HOUR.
NEARLY A QUARTER OF CLAIMANTS
REPORTED THEIR WAGES RECEIVED AN
HOURLY WAGE BETWEEN TEN AND
ELEVEN DOLLARS.
AND ONE IN FIVE CLAIMANTS WERE
PAID LESS THAN TEN DOLLARS PER
HOUR.
IN THE YEARS EXAMINED ALTHOUGH
MORE THAN FOREIGN FIVE WORKERS
REPORTED HOURLY WAGES AT THE
MINIMUM WAGE. ONE IN TEN OR MORE.
REPORTED THAT THEY RECEIVED LESS
THAN THE MINIMUM WAGE.
OVER A THIRD OF THE CASES FILED
WITH US -- WERE SETTLED. ONE IN
FIVE WERE EITHER ABANDONED BY
THE CLAIMANT AND 16% FAILED TO
APPEAR APPEAR FOR THEIR CASE.
THE SIX ZERO EXCUSE ME ONE SIX
SIX NINETEEN THANK YOU POLICIES.
IN TERMS OF RECOMMENDATIONS
GOING FORWARD.
THE DEPARTMENT IS CURRENTLY
CONDUCTING AN ADDITIONAL SURVEY
TO OBTAIN A TAPE OBTAINED IT
STAKEHOLDER INPUT.
ON OUR REGION EDUCATION
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE CENTURY
BOTH TO AFFECTED WORKERS AND
POSSIBLE EMPLOYERS.
MEMBERS OF THE SURVEY INCLUDE
MEMBERS OF THE INITIAL ADVISORY
COMMITTEE ESTABLISHED BY THIS
LEGISLATURE ATTHAT INCLUDES
LABOR MANAGEMENT.
WORKER ADVOCACY GROUPS AS WELL
AS ACADEMIC GROUPS THAT RE
FAMILIAR WITH THE SPECIFICS OF
THIS INDUSTRY.
AND FURTHER DETAILS WILL BE
INCLUDED IN THE REPORT PROVIDED
TO LATER THIS SUMMER.
THANK YOU I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THE QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
WHAT A SPECIFIC CHALLENGES IN
EDUCATING THE FORCING LABOR LAWS
FOR DOMESTIC WORKERS?
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION -- I
THINK THERE ARE SEVERAL.
I THINK ONE IS FOR LOW WAGE
POPULATIONS.
THERE IS A GENERALFEAR IN
COMING FORWARD TO A GOVERNMENT
ENTITY THAT SOMETHING THAT THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER AND NOW THE
LABOR SECRETARY HAS WORKED VERY
HARD TO OVERCOME.
WE HAVE PARTNERED WITH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
EMPLOYEE GROUPS AND AN EMPLOYER
GROUPS AS WELL TO HELP YOU OUT
REACH THOSE POPULATIONS -- GIVEN
THE NATURE OF THE WORKER
POPULATION SPECIFICALLY -- WE
NEED TO EMPLOY MULTIPLE
STRATEGIES IN ORDER TO REACH
THEM EFFECTIVELY -- AND HAVE
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE MATERIALS
THAT ARE.
EASILY TRANSLATABLE AND CAN.
CONVEY SOME OF THE COMPLEX LEGAL
ISSUES AND THE RIGHTS
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR BOTH THE
WORKERS AND THE EMPLOYERS AND AN
EASY TO UNDERSTAND MANNER SO
PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO COMPLY.
EARLY ON BUT EVEN WITH ALL THAT
STILL KIND OF A TOUGH TOUGH NUT
TO CRACK.
IT CAN BE CHALLENGING AREA.
WE ALSO WENT WHEN A QUESTION
THIS ADMINISTRATION SUPPORT
PROVIDING RESOURCES TO PROVIDE
OUT REGION EDUCATION THE
DOMESTIC WORKER INDUSTRY.
WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE ENFORCEMENT AND IMPROVE
COMPLIANCE SO THAT WORKERS ARE
TREATED APPROPRIATELY HAVE TO
CONFER WITH DEPARTMENT FINANCING
ADMINISTRATION ON SPECIFICS OF
THE PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU TODAY.
I THINK YOU.
WERE GOING TO OPEN UP PUBLIC
COMMENT -- LOOKING WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE FOLKS
MORE GLENN LINE UP.
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE THE STATE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION WITHIN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE.
HI AM SERRA SANDERS AND I'M A
RETIRED ATTORNEY AND I'M WITH
THE DOMESTIC WORKERS ALLIANCE
AND I CAN TELL YOU BASED ON
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE.
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS THAT THESE
RIGHTS ARE KNOWN BY THE
EMPLOYERS BECAUSE THEY WILL
FOLLOW IT MANY OF THEM IF THEY
KNOW ABOUT IT?
SO THANK YOU THANK YOU AND I'LL
Là SPEAK WITH MONIQUE HERIS.
WHICH WOULD BE.
TO YEAH DO.
WILL ALWAYS -- YEAH GO
[inaudible]
THE ONLY.
I'M MONEY KERIS AND I EMPLOY
ATTENDANCE AND I AM FOR THIS
BILL FOR EDUCATION I'M GOING TO
SEND THE CHILEAN TO THAT
HOLOCAUST.
HEY YOU UP FOR YOU.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S DANIELLE OFFERING I'M
WITH THE PROMOTE ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY CENTER AND I'M HERE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS PROGRAM AS
WELL.
THANK YOU.
WHEN I STARTED THURMOND NUMBERS
GOT TO MINGLE IT BINGO THE
THEY'VE GOT ENOUGH ON HER LIST
YOUR POOR YOUR?
IF.
IS TO BE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MICHAEL I END UP CALIFORNIA
LINES RETIRED AMERICANS -- WORDS
STRONG SUPPORTER THIS -- CARE
MUST BE VALUED HIGHER AND THAT
CAN NEVER HAPPEN WHEN CARE
GIVERS ARE ABUSED.
THANK YOU.
LEE HAMILTON -- WITHIN THEIR THE
CIVILITY ACTION AND WE ALSO AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
FOLLOWING A THOUGHT A MINIMUM
IDEA TO USE WE BRING QUE WHAT IS
HOW YOU'RE GOING TO SELL A
CANADIAN CITIZEN ULTRA COLORS
AND ALL THAT.
YOUR POOR YOUR TO PROPOSED.
THANK YOU.
WHEN A FELONY NUMBER SAID HE GOT
CHáVEZ LIKE THE HOLIDAY LAST
WEEK THE HUMBER SEQUEL
CALIFORNIA NAY THE LOCAL DILLON
WAITED SOME PRACTICAL YES I HAVE
OVER THE PROPOSED ADDRESS IF?
YOU.
WHEN IS THAT THE NUMBER THAT
MONEY FROM MIDDLE SAY THEY'LL
HAVE IT AT ELEVEN HE FINGER
LIKELY THE US EMBASSY?
YES CLEARLY AND EFFECTIVELY.
THANK YOU.
WHEN THE SEVEN NUMBERS NO MONEY
DOWN THEY MINGLE ALLOWS US TO
FEEL THIS SHEILA?
YES PLAY A POOR YOUNG LITTLE IS
DONE OR LA HE SO THEY LEVEL BUT
FROM THE MINUTE TELEPHONE
ECONOMIST.
THANK.
WHEN ASKED OTHERS BUT THEY
SUFFER LESS OUT OF THE BOTTOM
THEY LOOK AT LEAST HAVE THAT
ATTITUDE Là?
YEAH LANCE HOW THEY LEFT OFF A
LOT OF THE MYSTIC I SEE THEM IN
A POIGNANT.
I AND GRAHAM IS FAILURE OF
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BUDGET ASKS OF THESE.
MY NAME IS EDITH YOU SO HOLE
FROM FILIPINO WORKERS CENTER LOS
ANGELES AND I'M ALSO IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. ONE OF SEVEN THE
NUMBER MONEY A CLAIM EVEN WELL
THERE'S SOME THAT ARE ALSO.
THEY LIKE WHAT YOU SEE ON THEY
ACTIVATE THEM.
YEP FOR YOUR BILL THE LATEST
THAT IS -- FROM WEST.
THAT'S THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS A GOOD IDEA.
I'M REPRESENT OF MISSING RIGHT
ON THE LABOR CENTER INCENT
ACOSTA HIS THUMB SECOND BUT A
COUPLE YET.
HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME IS TORY
ARE NOW AND I AM IN FULL SUPPORT
OF THE DOMESTIC WORKERS
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH PROGRAM
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS MADE A YEAH I
AM -- WITH CHILLIN SOMEONE OF
THE NOT AND I SUPPORT THE BUDGET
REQUEST.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS APPEALING A STRAND OF
A SISTER AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FILIPINO WORKER CENTER
AND WHAT SPECIFICALLY IN OUR
REGION EDUCATION AND CASES
SPECIFICALLY.
AND I KNOW HOW IMPORTANT
EDUCATION IN OUR REGION THE
LINGUISTICALLY CULTURALLY -- AND
PERSONAL WAY WE CAN REALLY
EXPLAIN THESE LAWS ARE VERY
COMPLICATED YOU HELP THEM YOU
KNOW HOW PART AS I SUPPORT 1100%.
THANK YOU.
I AM THE THE BILL MOVE THEN AND
THEN THE ANY BRING BOTH GOOD
THEIR BOOTH.
IN THE WOMB THE WITH.
WORRY FILLED WITH ONE THE BLUE
DO YOU.
CAN BE GIVEN YOU'VE SEEN.
MOVE THOUGH WAS FULLY THE BULLS.
THE BY THE THE I'M SUCH A BIT.
I'M SORRY BETTER WITH HAND IN
HAND AND EVEN FOR A GOOD
EMPLOYERS THE RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES -- YOU CAN BE
CONFUSING SO I SPORTS PROGRAM
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON I'M CHRIS THE
FORENSIC NOT AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF
BELIEVE ME NO WORKERS CENTER
FROM THEM LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA
SO I'M WORKING US I CARE GIVER
FOR ALMOST FOUR YEARS SO.
AND 100% FULL SUPPORT. FOR FOR
THIS BILL IS ABOUT TO BEGIN A
PAID EQUALITY AND FAIRLY THANK.
YOU.
HI AMBER CALENDAR FLEUR FROM
PALMDALE AND I'M A MEMBER OF
CHIRLA AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
I AM SEVERE THE FLOW WITH CHIRLA
FROM PALMDALE AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WHEN I SEVEN WE NOTICED IN MY
CAREER WITH A MEMBER OF THE T.
LIVING THAT?
A LOOK AT I GUESS YOU AND THEY
BUT OLYMPIA THOUGH IT IS.
THANK YOU.
WHEN I FOUND THE NUMBER SEVEN
NOTHING MAKES EWING Là APPLE
YEAH WITH THEM -- PROPUESTAS.
CORRECT THANK YOU.
THE LAST SEVENTY NUMBER PHILLIP
DESOLATE IT IS SO I THOUGHT I'LL
HAVE ANOTHER MISTAKE.
WHEN AT THE LIMóN NUMBERS
CATALINA MORE AND EVEN GO THE
CHEAP Là AND THE LOS ANGELES
YEP FOR YOUR LAPTOP WITH?
MY NAME'S JULIE ROBERTS FONG IN
A DOMESTIC EMPLOYER FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS NANCY ZUNIGA
FROM LOS ANGELES EITHER UPS GUY
I WORK DOING OUT REACH EDUCATION
WITH DOMESTIC WORKERS AND MY
MOTHER HAS BEEN A DOMESTIC
WORKER HERSELF FOR OVER THIRTY
YEARS.
SO INSTRUCTORS THIS BUDGET ASK
THANK YOU.
MAY NUMBER IS MUDDY WET ADA.
THE OUTGOING IT ALREADY HE BINGO
THEY THIS GUY LOS ON HIM AT THE
APPLE U. S. THE PURPOSE.
HELLO MY NAME IS IN COMMERCE
WITH THE FILIPINO WORKER CENTER
IN LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA AND I
AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY
NAME IS LAURA AND BONE A LIVE IN
VALLEJO CALIFORNIA AND I'M FROM --
FLIPPING ON THE COULD JUSTICE
AND I SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY
NAME IS NORA MUSCLE I AM A
MEMBER OF THE PHILIPPINE I'VE
GET BORED JUSTICE AND MEAN IN
FOR THIS AFFORD THESE.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS NERDS VALIUM I AM
THE WORKER ORGANIZER FOR
PHILIPPINE ADVOCATES FOR JUSTICE
AND IN SUPPORT OF THIS PROGRAM
THANK YOU YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CATALINA AND I'M
CAME FROM SIMI VALLEY.
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS MADDIE YANKEE
N. AND I'M A MEMBER OF HAND IN
HAND -- I DO EMPLOY A VERY
COMPETENT HOUSE CLEANER.
AND I ALWAYS SAY THAT I LOVE
COMING HOME TO A CLEAN HOME.
BUT IF JUSTICE AND DIGNITY THAT
LIVE THERE FOR THEM WORKERS IT
WOULD BE NOTHING.
THANK YOU.
WHEN I STARTED THIS BINGO THE
ELECTS GOV?
YEP BOILER CORDLESS YOUNG MEN
NUMBER SOME IDEA KEEPING WITH
THE BUDGET WE BOUGHT A BY YOU
AND THAT YOU'LL BE ABLE WHICH IS
GONNA CYSTIC OF EUROPE IN THE
THE HUGH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CLAUDIA BUT LET'S HEAR SOME THE
COORDINATOR OF THE DOMESTIC
WORKER PROGRAM AT THE INSTITUTE
OF POPULAR EDUCATION.
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND I AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF THIS
REQUEST.
THANK YOU.
HELLO THERE I AM MERELY ABOUT
ANOTHER A I WAS THE CARE GIVER
FOR MANY YEARS.
AND I SUFFERED FROM THE NEURONS
OF MY RIGHTS.
AND TODAY I'M AN ORGANIZER FOR
DEVELOPING A WORKER CENTER LOS
ANGELES AND A WITNESS.
THE FEAR AND THE LACK OF
KNOWLEDGE OF MY FELLOW CARE
GIVERS.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL DEFINITELY
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO PROVIDE IN
THIS IS A MINUTE OVERNIGHT SHOW
FROM THE FILIPINO WORKER CENTER
AND I WORK SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
OR FIVE I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S KRISTY LIVE AND I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF THE GREAT DAY
LABOR CENTER AND ALMOST SINCE
AND I'M WEST NOT MY COUNTY.
AND I SUPPORT -- THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL FTA FOR DOMESTIC WORKER
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
I MEAN NUMBER IS THEY SEE
LOCUSTS AND SO YOU'RE NOT THAT
WERE CUT OUT OF THE US HAVE A
LAW THAT.
EASIEST LACKEY PINEAPPLE YET IS
THE PROGRAM OF THE BECAUSE YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M MICHELLE
MEDINA ADVOCATE FOR AT THE
FILIPINO WORKERS CENTER I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BUDGET ASK
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY NAME
IS LA HOLLY PLAZA I AM AN ACTIVE
WORKER LEADER OF THE FILIPINO
WORKERS CENTER.
I SUFFERED A CONSEQUENCE OF THAT
KNOWING MAY RISE FOR FEAR OF
LOSING MY JOB AS I WAS
UNDOCUMENTED AT THE TIME AND
TODAY I'M ORGANIZING MY FELLOW
CARE GIVERS.
AND I'M THE COMMUNITY TOGETHER
FOR YOU WC AND THE STORM IS THE
BOARD FOR THIS BUDGET ASK THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
WELL LET ME NUMBER DOESN'T
MATTER THAT HE IS THE STORY OF A
MEMBER THAT YOU LACK BINGO THE
LOS ANGELES UP WE END THIS THE
PARAMETER GUSTING OFFENSIVE.
THANK YOU.
I DON'T -- GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS ON THE JOSHUA COMMERCIAL.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL BOB DR
REVENUE MINISTER CIVIL RIGHTS
AND HUMAN RIGHTS NOT TO CARE MY
PARENTS TOO SO YOU KNOW I JUST
WANT SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
HAVE A GOOD DAY THANK YOU.
I WHEN I SERVICE THE NUMBER IS
THAT ONLY CAN BE AT THE ALSO YOU
THEM CRISTINA SIXTY WAS THE SAN
FRANCISCO YES THEY GIVE FOUR
YOUNG THOUGH IT PROGRAM EITHER A
GUN SAY YEP [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND I'M FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND
I'M A SHOW THEIR SUPPORT HIS
BILL NOW FOR THE WOMAN
COLLECTIVE.
THANK YOU. ONE OF THAT IS THAT
THE LOS YES YES AB WHAT IS WHICH
UNLESS YOU CAN THE PSYCHE E..
ME NUMBER IS A SEVEN PM AB ONE
SAN FRANCISCO IS LIKE GOING OUT
OR ANY SAYS YUP CLICK THE WHEN
THEY LOOK AT IS.
IT THE MINISTRY A KEY PART UP
WELL YEAH LE PROPOSE THAT GLASS
YES.
ROUGH.
WELL I WENT OUT OF THIS MAY
NUMBER IS ON THE FINAL BINGO
THEY SAN FRANCISCO IS A MEMBER
OF THEM QUITE AS WE NEED A FIFTY
OF US IN THE TOP WIDELY BASED ON
THE COST SIDE WITH ALL THE NINOS
IF THAT MEANS GOING UP WE HANDLE.
IS THAT PROPUESTAS.
THAT'S IF.
WHEN I DIALED IN THE NUMBER IS
BONUS ON THE?
ORIENTED PROGRAM NOT A THE CAUSE
YOU ANY OTHER CONCEPT BUT I
LOVED IT TO THE LAST.
SO HOW THE WHAT US THEY LOW BACK.
NORTH ROAD LONGHORN WAYS THAT
IDEALLY THAT.
THEIR CHILDREN.
BUT I THINK YOU.
WHEN IS THE LIMóN NUMBER IS
DEVELOPING SO THEM COULD EASILY
THE THICK THE US THEN?
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA.
E. YOUR UP ALL YOUR LAPTOP WITH
THEM BUT IT'LL COST YOU NEED
GUNS SO THAT THAT A WHOLE LOT OF
THEM AWAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LUIS
MARTINEZ TIME WITH MORE HEDISON
NEED US YET THE BEST AN
ORGANIZATION IN THE BAY AREA.
I WORK ORGANIZING DOMESTIC
WORKERS AND MY FAMILY IS
BENEFITTED FROM.
DECADES OF DOMESTIC WORKERS
WORKING TO TAKE CARE OF OUR
CHILDREN OUR ELDERS AND PEOPLE
WITH.
DISABILITIES IN OUR FAMILY THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
ME NUMBER IS ONE MILLION THAT
YOU.
REPRESENT THE WILL OF THE OFFICE
YOU KNOW THEY THEY THEY ONLY
[inaudible]
IS ME.
MEET OUR MY WHOLE THE HELLO TO
THE MYSTICAL.
YOLO UP WHEN GLOBAL YEAH IDEA TO
PRESENT THEM [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MEGAN ARE TO
USE WITH THE INSTITUTE OF
POPULAR EDUCATION OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EITHER SKY LOS
ANGELES.
AND I AM FULL SUPPORT OF THIS
BUDGET PROPOSAL BECAUSE WE STILL
HAVE WORKERS COMING IN GETTING
PAID TWO DOLLARS AN HOUR THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS NANCY
TOURISM ALSO WITH THE ANSWER TO
THE POPULAR LOCATION OF AN
ORGANIZER I HAVE.
HEARD SO MANY CASES OF WAGE
CLAIMS AND ALSO -- LAKE MEGAN
SAID HOW THE WORK IS NOT GETTING
BEING NOT EVEN THE MINIMUM WAGE
IS NOT ALLOWED TO EAT WITH THEIR
THEY WANT TO EAT AND I WOULD
LOVE IF YOU GUYS COULD SUPPORT
THIS.
PROPOSAL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S JACQUELINE
PRESENT I'M FROM LOS ANGELES
REPRESENTING IT UPSCALE SINCE A
PART OF THIS BUDGET.
THANK YOU.
HELLO ENOUGH LEVEL MINIMUM IDEA
OF IMMEDIACY SIGNAL A HELL OF A
MISTAKE I EVEN BEFORE YEAH.
THE PURPOSE.
GOOD AFTERNOON KIMBERLY AWAITING
THAT DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DOMESTIC WORKER COALITION HERE
IN FORCE FULL SUPPORT OF THE
BUDGET REQUEST. TO ENSURE THAT
THE THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOMESTIC WORKERS NO THEIR RIGHTS
AND THE TWO MILLION HOUSEHOLDS
THAT EMPLOY HIM.
CAN BECOME CAN BE FAIR EMPLOYERS
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ME NUMBER DOES NOT ADDRESS THE
DAY YOU GUYS DOING GO THAT
CENTRAL CORE MY LETTER UPON ONE
I UP FOR JUST A PROPOSED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MANUAL RUN AND I'M
MORE THAN ANYTHING AND SOMETHING
ON THE WIDELY FROM G. Là.
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL BY IT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
COULD HAVE RIGHT.
TIMES WHEN RUSHES THIS LEFT
CHILD AND I IF I ME TO SUPPORT
THIS -- BILL AND AND FOR FUNDING
AND AS THEY BOTH HAVE THEIR AN
EMPLOYER AND THAT'S THE MOTHER
WAS RAISED BY A NANNY -- SO.
YES ARE YOUR SUPPORT I GET THANK
YOU.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME NICKEL CITY
AS A IN OF THE NAVAL.
IN POMONA HE I SUPPORT THESE
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WHEN A SEVEN MAN I'M GONNA SOUND
THAT GROOVING GO THEY ORANGE
APPREHEND THE LAD?
LE PROPUESTAS THAT THAT I'M A
HELLO THIS ON MY SKIN THAT'S HIS.
WHEN I STARTED IN THE NUMBERS
RIGHT NOW MENDOZA EVEN WITH THIS
MONTH ON THE CALIFORNIA?
EAT UP FOR YOU IS THE PROPOSED
EIGHTH AMENDMENT WATER AT THIS
AND THEN THE LAST TIME HOW DOES
THE MISSED BECAUSE OF CONDELLO
THEY WOULDN'T [inaudible]
DRESSES.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN NUMBER IS A
STELLAR SOLOS BINGO IN CONTROL
OF THE ORANGE RIVER FOR YOUNGER
Là PROPOSED?
GET OUT HIS POLITICAL CHARM
THANK YOU.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MEGAN WHALEN IN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC WORKERS
COALITION AND I'M HERE I'M FROM
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT
THIS PROPOSAL THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON JUST GIVE OUR
FLOW WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE STRONGER
CALIFORNIA COALITION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON RENEE BAYARDO SO
YOU CALIFORNIA ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS A SEMI
KELLY OF FROM THE SENIOR AND
THIS UP IT DISABILITY TEAM OF
SAN FRANCISCO AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
HELLO -- MY NAME IS EMMA SITE IS --
FROM SANTA ANA CALIFORNIA AND
ORANGE COUNTY AND I'VE -- GROVE
WITH A DOMESTIC WORKER FAMILY MY
MOM SAID THE MOST A WORKER MY
SISTER.
I USED TO BE AT THE MOST A
WORKER AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WITH AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARIA
ESPADA I AM FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
AT BELOW TO SENIOR DISABILITY
ACTION AND I FLEW FULLY THE
FORGET THE YEAH A FULLY AT BOTH
BOTH.
THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SO
SIMPLISTIC OF COURSE OF COURSE
TO SCHOOL.
AND I BOTTOM TO SIMULATE
DISABILITY ACTION AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WELL YOU CAN TELL BY OUR
SPEAKERS WE'VE GOT JUST A
DIVERSE GROUP OF FOLKS -- CURLY
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM SO WE CAN'T
VOTE ON THIS BUT I WILL SAY.
THE MISTER WORKER HISTORY THE
UNIQUE IN HISTORY.
WORKERS ARE OFTEN MORE
VULNERABLE TO WORKPLACE
VIOLATIONS AND OTHER LOW WAGE
INDUSTRIES.
MANY WORKERS EMPLOYERS DO NOT
KNOW THAT THAT LAWS APPLY TO
DOMESTIC WORK.
THAT'S WHY I'M RECOMMENDING THE
SUBCOMMITTEE APPROVED THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL FIVE FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
OUT REGION EDUCATION.
THE DOMESTIC WORK INDUSTRY.
SO ONCE WE GET A QUORUM WE
SHOULD VOTE ON IT.
I WANT.
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
SO NEXT REMOVAL.
TO BEFORE YOU THAT SERGEANTS THE
CALL THAT THE NUMBER YOU KNOW
THANK YOU.
WE WANT ITEM NUMBER -- THREE
LEAD EXPOSURE LIMITS FOR WORKERS --
TWENTY THREE WITH GREG
[inaudible]
A CONNECTION [inaudible]
PRESIDENT.
SO IN SOME OF THE I. R..
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LEE
LOUDLY ON MONDAYS I'M THE
LEGISLATIVE COORDINATOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS.
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE AN UPDATE.
ON THE DEPARTMENT'S PROGRESS IN
REVISING THE LEAD STANDARDS WE
AGREE THAT THIS IS A CRITICAL
STANDARDS AND I'D LIKE TO SHARE
THE DETAILS OFF THE PROCESS.
THAT WE'VE BEEN GOING THROUGH TO
UPDATE OUR OF LEAD STANDARDS --
THE OF WORK STARTED IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN PROMPTED BY -- A
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH.
SINCE THEN WE'VE HELD SIX
ADVISORY MEETINGS WITH BOB TO
GET STAKEHOLDER INPUT --
INCLUDING INDUSTRY BY THE
MEDICAL COMMUNITY PUBLIC HEALTH
AUTHORITIES STATE AGENCIES AND
WORKERS BOB FROM THERE WE'VE
COME UP WITH SIX DIFFERENT
VERSIONS OFF THE REVISED LEAD
STANDARDS.
SIX SIX DIFFERENT CROPS -- THE
THE DROPS REQUIRED --
SIGNIFICANT SCIENTIFIC AND
TECHNICAL INFORMATION AN
ANALYSIS.
OF THE MEDICAL AND OTHER
INFORMATION.
SUPPLIED BY HEALTH AND
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENCE EXPERTS
HAD TO BE REVIEWED AND ASSESSED
FROM A NECK OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH
AND SAFETY PERSPECTIVE.
AND IT ALSO REQUIRES A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH THAT
TAKES INTO ACCOUNT NOT JUST THE
PERMISSIBLE EXPOSURE LEVEL BUT
OTHER.
BOB STANDARDS THAT NEED TO WORK
IN TANDEM WITH THAT.
P. L. -- IN ORDER FOR THE
STANDARDS TO BE EFFECTIVE AS A
WHOLE -- WE HAVE A DRAFT A FINAL
DRAFT -- THAT WAS.
BOB FINALIZED IN NOVEMBER -- TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN THAT FINAL
DRAFT STANDARDS.
BOB REQUIRED A STANDARD AS
STANDARDIZED REGULAR REGULATORY
IMPACT ANALYSIS OR SHRIYA -- AS
SERVE AS REQUIRED BY THE AT
MINUTES ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURES ACT FOR ANY
REGULATIONS WITH AN ECONOMIC
IMPACT.
OF OVER -- OF FIFTY MILLION OR
MORE -- THE US.
THAT -- STUDY WAS COMPLETED WITH
THE HELP OF AN OUTSIDE
CONSULTANT -- BEAR OR BERKELEY
ECONOMIC ADVISING AND RESEARCH.
AND THE DEPARTMENT HAS SHARED
THE SRI ARE INFORMALLY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE -- FOR
INPUT.
BOB THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF FIVE
FINANCES ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
REQUESTS HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED AND
WE'RE NOW IN THE PROCESS OF
UNDERGOING FINAL INTERNAL REVIEW --
AND WE EXPECT TO BE A BE IN A
POSITION TO BOB FORMALLY SUBMIT.
THOSE FREE -- TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE FOR APPROVAL -- THIS
SPRING EARLY SUMMER -- OF COURSE
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MUST
APPROVE -- THE SRI UP BEFORE --
FIVE FORMAL RULEMAKING CAM
COMMANDS -- AND ONE STEAL WAF
APPROVES THE THREE ARE THEN.
CALL OSHA SUBMITS THE PROPOSED
REGULATORY LANGUAGE TO VEHICLE
PICKED A CABINET -- SORRY
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
STANDARDS BOARD -- FOR ADOPTION
AND FORMAL ROOM RULE MAKING --
OF COURSE THE STANDARDS BOARD IS
AN INDEPENDENT BODY WITH ITS OWN
PROCEDURES.
AND THEY THEY NEED -- TO TO
APPLY THOSE PROCEDURES -- AND
BEFORE RULE MAKING.
CAN -- BEGIN ONCE FORMAL RULE
MAKING -- BEGINS WHEN THE
STANDARD STANDARDS BOARD IS
READY TO THE ISSUE THE NOTICE OF
PROPOSED RULEMAKING THEN IT
COULD TAKE UP TO ONE YEAR FOR
RULE MAKING -- SO WE ESTIMATE
THAT THE COMPLETION DATE -- FOR
THE ENTIRE REVISED LEAD
STANDARDS -- FOR GENERAL
INDUSTRY AND FOR CONSTRUCTION
OUT WOULD.
WOULD BE MADE. TWENTY TWENTY AND
THIS IS AGAIN THE REVISED THAT
THE REVISED.
LED STANDARD INCLUDING THE
PERMISSIBLE EXPOSURE LEVEL AND
THE OTHER -- STANDARDS THAT NEED
TO WORK IN TANDEM FOR THE FOR
THE P. L. TO BE EFFECTIVE AND
FOR PROTECT WORKER PROTECTIONS.
TO BE EFFECTIVE IN KEEPING
INCLUDING THE ACTUAL LEVEL --
WHICH IS THE TRIGGER FOR
EMPLOYERS TO TO ACT -- IN THE TO
PROTECT THEIR WORKERS AND THE
ALL OF THE OTHER STANDARDS THAT
GO WITH WITH THAT PACKAGE.
TOTAL SIX MEETINGS OVER THE LAST
EIGHT YEARS.
PARDON WE'LL SIX MEETINGS OVER
THE LAST EIGHT YEARS.
THEY WERE -- IN FACT THEY TOOK
PLACE FROM -- 200-011-22000
SIXTEEN SO IN EFFECT IT WAS
THOSE FIVE TO SIX YEARS -- THEN --
WHAT WHAT THE -- ALSO TOOK UP A
SUBSTANTIAL TIME IS THE
PREPARATION ALL OF OF THE SHARIA --
THAT IS A PROCESS THAT WE MUST
UNDERGO FOR ANY REGULATION THAT --
WILL HAVE AN IMPACT OF FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS OR MORE -- AND
THAT IS AN EXTENSIVE STUDY -- IN
PARTICULAR FOR THE FOR IN IN
THIS CASE -- IT WAS A COMPLEX
STANDARD SO -- IT IT TOOK AN
ADDITIONAL AMOUNT OF TIME SO WE
HAVE A HAD A MEETING THE PAST
THREE YEARS.
THE LAST MEETING WAS IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN CORRECT.
THE LAST MEETING I BELIEVE WAS --
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THEN THE
DRAFT THE FINAL DRAFT REGULATION
WAS PREPARED -- AND THE OF THE
MYSTERY A WAS WAS COMMENCED
AFTER THE FINAL DRAFT REGULATION
IN THE TIME.
AND THAT. FOR THOSE THREE YEAH
YES -- THE SHARIA TOOK A
SUBSTANCE EXTENSIVE AMOUNT OF OF
TIME AND WORK TO TO GET
COMPLETED BUT IN THIS IN THESE
THREE YEARS -- THE DEPARTMENT
HAS ALSO BEING OUT IN COUNCIL OF
HAS CONSULTED DEAL LAUGH --
INFORMALLY ON THE CONTENTS OF
THIS RIA AND HAS -- HAS GONE
BACK TO RESOLVE THOSE ADDITIONAL
REQUEST FOR FOR INFORMATION
[inaudible]
MR HAIR.
BUT SHERMAN WAS IN HERE.
OF ALSO MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE AS
WELL -- TO YOU I'M NOT GOING TO
BORE YOU TOO MUCH OF THE HISTORY
THE LABORS ORGANIZATION
NATIONWIDE IS HAVING A A HUGE
MARKET SHARE IN THE REMEDIATION
INDUSTRY.
OPPORTUNITY IN CALIFORNIA THAT
PERMITS CONTROL BY 90% IF NOT
BETTER WHEN IT COMES REMEDIATION
NOW IN THE LEAD ABATEMENT ALSO
THE HAZARDOUS WASTE MATERIALS OF
ALL OF ALL TYPES OF THAT ARE.
BEEN IDENTIFIED AS AS IS WHICH
IS IN THE STATE.
I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THAT --
THERE'S A PROCESS AND IS A DUE
PROCESS NEEDS TO BE TAKING PLACE.
WE HAVE BEEN VERY CONCERNED IN
ALWAYS AS ORGANIZATION BUT MANY
OTHERS ALSO TRAIN AND RECERTIFY
THESE WORKERS THE BY THE WAY IS
A VERY FILTHY WORK. TO TO
PERFORM -- THEY'RE THEY'RE
EXPOSED THERE'S LIMITS THAT HAVE
NOT BEEN AS IS OR YOUR STATED
LIMITS I HAVE NOT BEEN UPDATED
SO MANY YEARS THAT WE CONTINUE
TO EXPOSE THE SAME WORKERS.
AND NEW WORKERS TO COME INTO THE
INDUSTRY AND WE'RE JUST MAKING
THE CLAIM THAT AT ALL POSSIBLE
TO EXPEDITE THE PROCESS TO BE
ABLE TO LOWER THESE LIMITS.
GO TO THE PROCESS EXPEDITE THE
PROCESS AT ALL POSSIBLE -- IN
CALIFORNIA WE'VE BEEN HAVING THE
UNFORTUNATE SITUATION OF HAVING
THESE DISASTERS FIRES WHERE THIS
TYPE OF WORK ACTIVITY HAS BEEN.
KEY TO THE TO THE CLEAN UP
OPERATIONS OF OUR FIRES BOTH THE
NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA --
YOU FIND A LOT OF LEAD ABATEMENT
WITHIN A VERY IS -- OLD
BUILDINGS.
THAT THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE STATE
IN OUR COMPANIES ARE CONTRACTORS%
ARE CONTINUING TO MONITOR THE
EXPOSURE LIMITS BUT TO THE
DEGREE THAT.
UNTIL THEIR REDUCE WILL CONTINUE
TO EXPOSE UNNECESSARY AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE DUE TO THE LIMITS NOT
BEING.
UPDATED.
AGAIN I I CERTAINLY RESPECT WITH
THE DEPARTMENT HAS TO DO.
BUT I'D REALLY WOULD INSIST THAT
WHATEVER WE COULD POSSIBLY DO TO
BE ABLE TO EXPEDITE THE PROCESS
WOULD BE EXTREMELY.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATIVE ON BEHALF
OF ALL THESE WORDS IN THE STATE.
SO IT WAS DISCUSSED TALKING
ABOUT IS A DATE OF A NURSING A
NEW DATE OF FEBRUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY THAT'S TEN MONTHS
AWAY.
IS THAT REALISTIC.
WE BELIEVE THAT -- FOR THE
COMPREHENSIVE STANDARD -- A DATA
MAY TWENTY TWENTY WOULD BE
REALISTIC AND WHEN I SAY
COMPREHENSIVE STEP THAT STANDARD
I I MEAN NOT JUST THE THE P. L.
THE PERMISSIBLE PERMISSIBLE
EXPOSURE LEVEL.
BUT THE ENTIRE STANDARD
INCLUDING THE ACTUAL LEVEL --
WHICH IS THE SET THE THE
STANDARD THAT TRIGGERS THE
PROTECTIVE MEASURES.
BOB BEFORE HARM OCCURS BECAUSE
THE P. L. WORKS -- TO TO SET THE
LINE FROM WHERE HARM WOULD OCCUR --
BUT THE ACTUAL LEVEL IS THE ONE
THAT TRIGGERS THE PROTECTIVE
MEASURES AND THE STANDARD THAT
THE DIVISION IS CURRENTLY
WORKING ON AND AND WE HOPE -- TO
TO TO SENT TO THE BOARD -- IN A
IN IN THE NEXT FEW MONTHS.
HOW IS COMPREHENSIVE SO INC IT
WOULD INCLUDE THE P. L. BUT IT
ALSO WOULD INCLUDE THE ACTION
LEVEL?
AND OTHER STANDARDS AS WELL THAT
MAKE THAT PROTECTION -- REAL.
I GUESS MY ONLY CONCERN IS THAT
IF IF IS THAT REASONABLE IS THAT
REALISTIC IT'S BEEN AT THIS A
LONG TIME COMING.
AND I'M NOT A SCIENTIST BUT
STILL WE'RE NOT DEALING WITH
SOMETHING THAT'S OUT OF THE
ORDINARY Là FOLKS HAVE DEALT
WITH THERE'S A LOT OF
INFORMATION OUT THERE SO.
AND THIS ISN'T CUTTING EDGE
[inaudible]
SCIENCE.
IS BEING DONE ELSEWHERE SO.
THIS IS A CONCERNS BEEN SO LONG.
IT WILL REALLY HAPPEN IN TWENTY
AT SOME POINT SO MUST BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
AND TO ME LAST ME OCCURRED THREE
YEARS AGO AND TO GET A REPORT IT
TAKES THREE YEARS AGO REPORT --
AFTER CALL B. S. ON THAT -- I
JUST I JUST NOT SURE WHERE IT
GOT DROPPED AT THESE WORKERS ARE
BEING EXPOSED LEVEL IT'S IT'S
REAL.
IT'S DANGEROUS -- IS IT IT'S
IT'S UNACCEPTABLE THAT WE CAN'T
GET IT DONE SOONER AND QUICKER
STILL SOMEWHERE.
IN MY OPINION AND LET'S GET
MONTH SCIENTISTS -- BEEN
DRAGGING OUR THE BALLS BEEN
DROPPED SO -- THE QUESTION
COMMITTEE WHICH LACKEY
[inaudible]
NO SIR.
A THE GOAL IS TO HAVE THIS YEAR
I I JUST LIKE TO ADD ONE MORE --
BUT I THINK IT'S CERTAINLY
RELEVANT.
IS LONG AS THESE LEVELS ARE NOT
ADJUSTED.
THE INDUSTRY CONTINUES TO IN
MANY CASES.
CONSIDER THIS TO BE.
BECAUSE THEY COULD GO AHEAD AND
WORK UNDERNEATH THESE LEVELS
THAT HAVE BEEN.
AT THIS OVER SO HIGH FOR SO LONG.
THE CONTINUE TO PERFORM THIS
ABATEMENT.
UP UNTIL THAT POINT TO GET THAT.
THAT IS SO HIGH THAT THEY CAN
BID ON IT FOR THE LACK OF THE
IMPROPER LICENSE.
IN OTHER WORDS FOR DEMOLITION
TYPE WORK.
THEY COULD GET AWAY WITH DO A
LOT OF DEMOLITION WORK WITHOUT
HAVING TO DO THE APPROPRIATE
MEASURES.
BECAUSE OF THE LEVELS IF THESE
LEVELS DON'T COME DOWN THEY WERE
EXPOSING KNOWING THE WORKERS
WITH THE GENERAL POPULATION AT
LARGE.
NOW ANY EMPLOYERS REFORM HIS
TYPE OF WORK SORRY UNDERSTANDS
WHAT IS REQUIRED TO BE ABLE TO
PROTECT THE GENERAL POPULATION
IN FACT IS BE PERFORMED.
WELL PEOPLE AROUND.
BUT THAT'S ANOTHER FACTOR REALLY
CONSIDER AND THAT'S THE REASON I
THINK THEY WERE SO.
I THINK THAT THE PART WHATEVER
EVERYTHING POSSIBLY DUE TO BE
ABLE TO EXPEDITE THIS WOULD BE
EXTREMELY APPRECIATED ONCE AGAIN.
AND WHEN WERE THE LEVELS
ESTABLISHED HOW LONG AGO.
IN THE NINETIES.
IT'S BEEN A WHILE [inaudible]
S..
WE'RE GOING OVER THE PUBLIC
COMMENT.
YEAH FOR THE AYE ARE UNRELATED.
QUESTION -- CAN BRIGHTEN UP THE
ON THE WAIT LIST FOR THE GARMENT
RESTITUTION FUND.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MY NAME IS GREG EDWARDS I'M THE
CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER FOR DR.
CURRENTLY THE WAIT LIST -- FOR
THE GARMENT FLATTENED.
IS MY VOICE -- IS APPROXIMATELY.
THREE HUNDRED OR SO CLAIMS --
NOW WHEN I SAY THREE HUNDRED
CLAIMS THESE ARE THREE HUNDRED
CLAIMS FOR THE RESTITUTION FUND
ITSELF.
NOT THREE HUNDRED CLAIMS THAT
ARE IN THE ENTIRE PIPELINE A
PART OF THE PROCESS IS TO FIRST
TRY TO RECOVER -- FROM THE
RESPONSIBLE EMPLOYER AND WIN
BATTLES THOSE EFFORTS FATAL THEN
THE RESTITUTION FUND SERVES AS A
SAFETY NET FOR THOSE WORKERS --
WHO WERE -- THE VICTIMS OF WAIT
STAFF AND SO THE RESTITUTION
FUND ITSELF WHICH IS THE THING
AT ISSUE -- HAS APPROXIMATELY --
THIRTY HUNDRED CLAIMS IN.
ALL ON THE WAIT LIST IF YOU WILL --
YOU MAY RECALL -- THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT PROVIDED A
MECHANISM FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
TO TRANCE FOR FUNDS FROM THE
UNPAID WAGE FUND FOR THIS
PURPOSE -- THAT FIRST TRANSFER
IT TOOK AWHILE FOR THOSE MONIES
TO ACCUMULATE THAT FIRST
TRANSFER IS PENDING AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER THAT IS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
ALL RIGHT NOW A WE HOPE THAT
SHOULD SUFFICIENT FUNDS
ACCUMULATE BEFORE THE END OF THE
FISCAL YEAR WE WILL WILL EXECUTE
THE SECOND -- EXECUTIVE CHANCE --
FOR Và THAT WILL RESOLVE
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY OF THOSE CLAIMS THAT ARE
ON THE WAIT LIST OF THIS FISCAL
YEAR SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
WITHIN THE NEXT. SIXTY DAYS OR
SO.
THE REMAINING FORTY CLAIMS HAVE
ACCUMULATED IN THE OF THIS
FISCAL YEAR SO THOSE WERE CLAIMS
THAT WERE NOT IN VIEW OR OR TO
OUR KNOWLEDGE OR HAD NOT REACHED
THIS POINT IN THE PROCESS.
WHEN WE SUBMITTED OF THE B. C.
P. FOR CONSIDERATION LAST FISCAL
YEAR?
LET EXPOSURE FOR WORKERS OF THE
SERIOUS ISSUE.
EXPOSURE LIMITS TO BE ADDRESSED
IN A TIMELY MANNER -- DR NEEDS
TO WORK IN THE LEGISLATURE AND
STAKEHOLDERS IN PROVIDING
FREQUENT UPDATES THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE.
WHEN ALL THIS ITEM OPEN?
NEXT OF THIS YOU.
FOR FOCUS ON PUBLIC COMMENT I'M
SORRY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE JUST GIVE OUR
FLOW WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY.
I'M HERE AT TAKE SUBMIT TO YOU
AT PUBLIC TESTIMONY FROM GARMENT
CENTER WORKERS WHO ARE PENDING
AS THEIR PAYMENT FROM THE
RESTITUTION FUND -- I'D LIKE --
TO OUT I'LL GIVE THIS TO YOU
BOTH IN SPANISH AND ENGLISH --
BOTH COPIES BUT TO BRIEFLY AT
READ FROM MISTER PROBLEM
HERNANDEZ MINING TOWN.
HE SAYS HE'S A GARMENT WORKER.
HE'S ONE OF FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
GARMENT WORKERS IN LA.
HE'S BEEN A GOVERNMENT WORKER
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND TWO ANY
OPERATES AN OVERLOCK MARSH
MACHINERY.
HE WORKED IN A FACTORY FOR TEN
YEARS MAKING WOMEN'S CLOTHES
FROM A SHIRT AND DRESSES TO
HOODIES AS WELL SHORTS AND PANTS.
AND WITH THE OVERLOOKED MACHINES
HE JOINS THE GARMENTS TOGETHER.
THESE FACTORIES AND THE MAJORITY
OF GARMENT FACTORIES PAID BY THE
PIECE.
AND THE PAY THAT YOU GET IS
DEPENDING ON HOW MANY PIECES YOU
MAKE.
IN OVER LOCK HE EXPLAINS.
YOU HAVE TO WORK SIXTY HOURS TO
MAKE FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS.
THIS IS NOT ENOUGH TO SURVIVE IN
LOS ANGELES.
IN THE FACTORY THERE'S NO WATER
OR DRINK AND A LOT OF DUST.
THEY DON'T GIVE US MASKS OR
GLOVES AND WE NEED TO PREVENT
THAT WE NEED TO PREVENT US FROM
BREATHING IN THE DA'S.
WE BREATHE IN THE DUST AND IT'S
BAD FOR OUR LONG.
AFTER TEN YEARS HE WAS FIRED
UNJUSTLY.
AND THIS IS BECAUSE HE REFUSED
TO STAY AT WORK BETWEEN SIX AM
AND SEVEN PM WITHOUT BEING PAID
WAGES FOR THOSE TIME PERIODS.
HE FELT HIS CASE IN JUNE OF
TWENTY TWELVE BUT THE LABOR
COMMISSION AND TWENTY SIXTEEN
HIS CASE ENTERED INTO THE STATE
FUND HE'S BEEN WAITING SENSE.
HE APPRECIATES THAT YOU WILL
ACCEPT HIS STORY AND THE STORY
AND DECLARATIONS OF ABOUT A
DOZEN OTHER OF HIS CO WORKERS
WHO ARE ALSO WAITING FROM THE
FUND.
HE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS REQUEST THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON SERRA LEEDOM
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC
WORKERS COALITION AND WE'RE ALSO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU YOU.
MY NAME IS A QUARTER OF THE S.
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU -- ME
NUMBER DAYS MIGHT BE ACT QUALITY.
HE EVEN LOVE A OUT OF THAT BUT
THAT THAT UNLESS HE APPLE YOUR
KEEP THEM IN THAT.
SPAN.
BUT THIS YEAR.
I AM COMMITTED TO TRANSLATE MY
VEHICLE LEAN WITH UNLESS THE
GREAT AND DAY LABOR CENTER AND
I'M ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
BOTH.
BUT INSTEAD OF IN THE NUMBER OF
BIG EVENTS HE'S CO E. IS THE
THIRTY DAY CENTER ALSO YOU
BINGLE REPRESENT ON MUST THEM
COULD AS WE NEED THIS.
YES WE HAVE WE AND BUT I THINK --
ALSO FROM SANTA ROSA -- I'M HERE
WITH UNLESS AT THE GREAT AND DAY
LABOR CENTER IS WOMEN UNITED
PROGRAM AND HERE TO SUPPORT.
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEGAN ARE TO USE
FOR THE DUBS CON LOS ANGELES
ALSO LOS ANGELES WORKERS CENTER
NOT WORKING HERE IN SUPPORT.
OF THE GARMENT WORKERS REQUEST
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JUSTINA YASSER I'M
HERE AT THE CENTER FOR WORKERS
RIGHTS AND WE ALSO RENTS PURPOSE
BUDGET PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
GIVEN ALL THAT I'LL OPEN NEXT
MOVE ON ISSUE NUMBER -- FOUR
SUBSEQUENT INJURY BENEFIT TRUST
FUND.
AT THE BOTTOM OF THE
HOUSTON
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
AT THE REQUEST BEFORE YOU WILL
IT IS -- A REQUEST FOR SUPPORT
FOR THE UNIT THAT ACTUALLY
PROCESSES.
THE SUBSEQUENT INJURY BENEFIT
CLAIMS -- CURRENTLY -- AS NOTED
IN THE STAFF RIGHT UP.
THE CASE LOAD -- BORN OF BY
THOSE -- WORKERS WHO PROCESS
THESE CLAIMS EVALUATE THE CLAIMS
REVIEW THE CLAIMS MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
TO THE ATTORNEYS WHO REPRESENT.
THE STATE IN THESE CASES HOW THE
CASE LOAD OF APPROXIMATELY ONE
THOUSAND PER CASE WORKER -- THE
THE REASON THAT THAT MATTERS.
IS BECAUSE IT IS BASED ON THEIR
CASE WORK -- OF THAT THE
ATTORNEYS ARE ABLE TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE JUDGE.
OUR WHO IS PRESIDING OVER THE
CASE.
THIS IS PARTICULARLY CRITICAL IN
CASES WHERE -- 1100% DISABILITY
IS ALLEGED.
AND SO -- BECAUSE THEY CANNOT
MANAGE THE WORKLOAD -- THAT THEY
HAVE MORE OFTEN THAN NOT IN
THOSE 1100% DISABILITY CASE --
CASES WHEN THEY COME FORWARD --
THERE THE STATE LACKS THE%
EVIDENCE TO OBJECTIVELY EVALUATE
THE CLAIM AND SOUL.
THE JUDGES LAUGHED WITH THIS
RULING AND I QUOTE.
IN THE ABSENCE OF ANY
INFORMATION TO THE CONTRARY I
MUST AWARD -- FOR THE CLAIM IT.
TO THE TUNE OF A 100% DISABILITY.
THIS REQUEST WILL -- BRING THAT
CASE LOAD -- BACK INTO A REALM
THAT IS REASONABLE IT IS NOT
PERFECT BUT IT IS A REALM THAT
IS REASONABLE BY COMPARISON.
THE CASELOAD THAT A SKIFF CASE
WORKER HAS IS APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY KICKS THIS
WILL BRING THE CASELOAD OF THESE
WORKERS DOWN TO AROUND.
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY THAT IS --
IN A IN A NUTSHELL IF YOU WILL
THE PURPOSE FOR THIS ASK
[inaudible]
BUT IT'S GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
DANIEL BRANDON WITH DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE I WOULD JUST NOTE AS
I NOTED IN THE AGENDA THAT THE
TRAILER BILL FROM THIS HAVE BEEN
REMOVED -- AND SO -- THERE WAS A
QUESTION THAT WE HAVE THE ANSWER
WITH RELATION WE THINK THAT THIS
IS.
AN IMPORTANT REQUEST TO BRING
DOWN THE NUMBER WE NEED TO PAY
ATTENTION TO THESE CASES -- AND
REALLY PER SPOTLIGHT ON THEM AND
WE'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS [inaudible]
LL.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHATS OUT WITH
THE LA -- ON WE DON'T HAVE
SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
HOUSES ON THIS PROPOSAL BUT HAVE
TO WORK WITH STAFF ON QUESTIONS
THAT COME UP IN THE FUTURE.
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
WITH A SNIFF CAN AMOUNT OF
RESOURCES FOR D. I. R. PROCESS
CLAIMS.
RELATED SUBSEQUENT INJURY
BENEFIT TRUST FUND.
DOES THE ADMINISTRATION BELIEVE
THIS PROPOSAL.
WILL REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF CLAIMS
PAID OUT.
MARK MINUTES DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- YES WE DO -- THE
PROGRAM -- CURRENTLY HAS OVER
TEN THOUSAND OPEN CASES --
INCREASING BY ABOUT 26% ANNUALLY
ESSENTIALLY THIS IS -- THIS --
JUST THESE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
WILL RIGHT SIZE IT DEPARTMENT
BACK TO WHERE IT SHOULD BE TO
HANDLE OF ALL OF THOSE CASES TO
ABOUT -- THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
DOWN -- TO DOWN FROM ONE
THOUSAND CASES PER STAFF MEMBER
DOWN TO THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
WHICH IS A LOT MORE MANAGEABLE
AND OUT WILL ALLOW THE DIR -- TO
IT HANDLED THE CASE IS BETTER
OKAY.
ANYONE THE PUBLIC WHICH MAY COME
OF THIS ITEM.
OKAY WERE HOMELESS ISSUE OPEN TO
FURTHER CONSIDER THE REQUEST FOR
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS WITH
ALTERNATIVES FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL.
HE SHOULD BE HELD BUT I CAN
WRESTLE ON THIS NUMBER.
FIVE EMPLOYMENT BUILDING
DEPARTMENT DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN HOW ARE YOU HOW
ARE YOU GOOD -- AT THE AND IN AN
ATTEMPT TO HELP.
MOVE THINGS ONCE I IF IT'S OKAY
FOR JUST PRESENT THIS -- TO
ISSUE ITEMS FIRST OF THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT THIS IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE -- REALLY AIR
CONDITIONING AND OUR OFFICES IN
MODESTO AMBER SAID IT GETS REAL
HOT -- AND IT'S ABOUT TIME WE
REPLACE THESE -- TWO IMPORTANT
SYSTEMS.
I WAS VERY SUCCINCT [inaudible]
FINANCE.
WE HAVE NOTHING TO ADD THANK YOU --
ANY ONE KNOW THE PUBLISHING
COMING THIS ITEM.
I GOT MY AGE THAT HER PLACE LAST
YEAR SO I KNOW IT'S VERY
EXPENSIVE AND YOU NEED IT.
SO I KNOW CONCERNS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL HOWEVER IN
HOMELESS OPEN.
EVERY VISIT THE MAY REVISE.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU.
THIS WILL ON THE ITEM NUMBER SIX
PAID FAMILY LEAVE.
THIS IS THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
TO TAKE THE FIRST STEP -- IN --
TAKING A LOOK AT THE PAID FAMILY
PROGRAM IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA INCREASING -- THE
BENEFIT DURATION FROM SIX TO
EIGHT WEEKS -- FOR BOTH FUNDING
CARE AS WELL AS WILL BECOME
EXIGENCY -- IT ALSO ALLOWS US TO
MOVE EXPEDITIOUSLY -- TO
COMPLETE THE PROJECT -- AS WELL
AS LOWERING -- THE THE ANNUAL
DISBURSEMENTS TO COVER -- AND
RESERVE REQUIREMENTS EXCUSE ME --
TO MAKE SURE THAT IS RIGHT SIZED
[inaudible]
FINANCE -- NO FURTHER COMMENTS.
L. L..
THANK YOU YES ON THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THAT SPECIFIES THE
CHANGES THAT THAT THE GOVERNOR
IS IS PROPOSING WAS ONLY
RELEASED -- JUST SEVERAL DAYS
AGO SO WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REVIEW THE THAT THE POLICY
ITSELF OR THE THE FISCAL
ESTIMATES THAT THE THE
DEPARTMENT HAS PROVIDED
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT POLICY --
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A CLOSER LOOK
AT IT SPEAK WITH APARTMENT
ADDITIONALLY AND US WOULD
CONSIDER THIS ISSUE. FOR YOU AND
YOUR STAFF AS PART OF THE MAY
REVISION.
CHEMICAL AND OPEN UP PUBLIC
COMMENT.
IF UNANIMOUS NOTS KNOWN TO HAVE
THE CHILDREN NOW IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR PAID FAMILY LEAVE
LOOK FORWARD.
TO GETTING MORE DETAILS AND
SUPPORTING POLICIES THAT ARE
PROVIDE A WIN WIN FOR FAMILIES
AND BABIES AND AND PARENTS FOR
BONDING AND WITHOUT SACRIFICING
THEIR ECONOMIC SECURITY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
STARTER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION WE HAVE A
SUPPORT OF AMENDED POSITION ON
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE --
SUPPORT IN THAT WE VERY MUCH
AGREE THAT THE PAID FAMILY
PROGRAM SHOULD BE EXPANDED THAT
WE DON'T BELIEVE SIX WEEKS IS
ENOUGH TO ADEQUATELY BOND WITH
CHILDREN OR OFTEN TO CARE FOR
LOVED ONES BUT WE ARE A LITTLE
CONCERNED WITH THE WAY THAT IT'S
FUNDED -- THE WAY THAT IT
CURRENTLY IS PROPOSED TO BE
FUNDED BY WEAKENING THE SOLVENCY
OF THE ENTIRE DE I FUND.
AND THAT THOSE SOLVENCY
STANDARDS WERE CREATED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN AFTER THE
PROGRAM WAS ESSENTIALLY IN THE
RED FOR TWO YEARS.
AND THEN -- IN NINETEEN NINETY
TWO AFTER ANOTHER PERIOD WHERE
STATUTE -- WITHDREW THAT
STANDARD ALSO WENT BANKRUPT
AGAIN AND GIVEN THAT THE
DISABILITY INSURANCE FUND PAYS
FOR ESSENTIALLY WORKERS -- TO TO
CARE FOR THEMSELVES WHEN THEY'RE
INJURED SO SEVERELY THAT THEY
CAN THEY CAN NO LONGER WORK IN A
SUPPORT THEMSELVES.
WERE EXTREMELY CONCERNED ABOUT
ANYTHING THAT MIGHT WEAKEN THE
ABILITY OF THAT FUN TO CONTINUE
AND WE WOULD STRONGLY URGE THAT
OTHER FUNDING MECHANISMS WHETHER
IT'S AN EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTION OR
SOME OTHER METHOD BE EXPLORED IN
ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
PROTECT THE HEALTH OF THE AYE
FUND.
THANK YOU.
A COUPLE QUESTIONS -- WILL BE
THE ROLE OF THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED TASK
FORCE ON PAID FAMILY LEAVE.
I I EXPECT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WILL BE INVOLVED -- IT'S THE
TASK FORCE ITSELF IS COMING
TOGETHER AS WE SPEAK I KNOW THAT.
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICES HAD
SEVERAL CONVERSATIONS WITH
DIFFERENT LEGISLATORS AND
LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP.
ON THE ISSUE.
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES TO USE A
PORTION OF THE RESERVE WITHIN
THE DISABILITY INSURANCE.
FUND THE DOWN PAYMENT ON THE
EXPANDING FIT ON EXPANDING PAID
FAMILY LEAVE.
WILL BE THE IMPACT ON THE
STABILITY OF THE FUND.
CONSIDERING IN THE RED WHAT
TWICE WE JUST HEARD -- SO -- SO
THE TO MAINTAIN A RESERVE OF
25235% -- FOR THE RESERVE RATIO
WOULD BE AMENDED TO MAINTAIN A
RESERVE OF ABOUT 25235% OF
ANNUAL DISBURSEMENT THAT'S
SUPPOSED TO THE 45250% --
RESERVE CURRENTLY TO DELIVER THE
EXPANDED BENEFITS WITH MINIMAL
IMPACTS -- TO BY WITH MIDDLE
MINIMAL IMPACT ON EMPLOYEE
CONTRIBUTIONS -- DID
ADMINISTRATION IS CONFIDENT THIS
TO BUFFER -- WILL -- THIS NEW
BUFFER AMOUNT WILL BE SUFFICIENT
TO ABSORB FLUCTUATIONS AND
REVENUES TO TRIP FUTURE ECONOMIC
DOWNTURNS IN CHANGING DEMAND FOR
SERVICES.
WHAT IS THE MINISTRATION PROPOSE
INCREASING THE DURATION OF PAID
FAMILY LEAVE INSTEAD OF?
THE WAGE REPLACEMENT RATE SURE --
SO PUBLIC HEALTH AND I'M
ECONOMIC RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
PROVIDING I SIX MONTHS OF PAID
PARENTAL LEAVE THE NORM IS NOT
IN MOST DEVELOPED COUNTRIES --
THESE TO POSITIVE HEALTH AND
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES FOR
CHILDREN GREATER OP.
GREATER ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES
FOR PARENTS AND LESS STRAIN ON
FINDING AND AFFORDING INFANT
CHILD CARE.
SO THEY BRING ARE THEY BRING
PREMATURE AND SHOULDN'T A LOT OF
TASK FORCE TO CONSIDER HOW TO
BEST EXPAND PAID FAMILY LEAVE.
COMPREHENSIVELY -- WELL -- WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS A GREAT
NEED AND WE THINK THAT THIS IS A
PRETTY NEXT STEP IN ADDRESSING
THE NEED SO WHAT'S THE USE THE
TASK FORCE AND WORLD THAT THE
TASK FORCE WILL BE -- WORKING TO
CONSIDER OTHER OPTIONS INCLUDING
ALIGNING WORKER PROTECTIONS ON
TO THAT -- TO FAMILIES CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF OF THIS NEW PROGRAM.
AMONG MANY OTHER.
POLICY OPTIONS OKAY THANK YOU
FEEL EVEN THE SENSUAL AND
SUPPORTING WORKING FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
I SUPPORTERS PROGRAM LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND MY COLLEAGUES
IN THE LEGISLATURE ON EFFORTS TO
EXPAND THE PROGRAM.
HOWEVER THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IS VERY
NARAL SOLUTION.
THE LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR
SHOULD LOOK HOLISTICALLY AT THIS
PROGRAM.
CONSIDERING THE EXPANSION.
WILL THIS ITEM OPEN LIKE FORTY
MINISTRATION WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON ANY PROPOSED
EXPANSION [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THAT'S WHAT OTHER NUMBER SEVEN
CALIFORNIA WORK FIRST
DEVELOPMENT BOARD.
REMOVING BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT
ACT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
TIM RAINY CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR -- THE AB ELEVEN ELEVEN
THE REMOVING BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT IS A UNIQUE GRANT
PROGRAM FOR SERVING
DISADVANTAGED WORKERS.
WITH SICK SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS
TO EMPLOYMENT.
THE GAP THAT'S OUT THERE THAT
WE'VE SEEN IN MY MANY YEARS OF
DOING WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT --
THERE A COUPLE THEIR MANY BUT
ALL OF POINT OUT A COUPLE
RELEVANT TO THIS THIS BILL.
AT THE FIRST IS RESOURCES FOR
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES -- THINGS
LIKE TRAUMA INFORMED CARE
STIPENDS.
THE CHILD CARE RESOURCES --
VARIOUS GOT MENTORING -- THE
KINDS OF THINGS THAT PUBLIC
DOLLARS TEND NOT TO FIND ENOUGH --
BUT THEY'RE NECESSARY TO GET
PEOPLE UP TO A POINT.
WHERE THEY'RE GONNA SUCCEED IN
HIGHER LEVEL -- TRAINING AND
EMPLOYMENT PROGRAMS -- THE
SECOND IS COMMITTEE BASS
ORGANIZATIONS AROUND THE STATE.
DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
CONNECT TO THE BROADER WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT SYSTEM UP THERE
SMALL MISSION DRIVEN ECONOMIC
JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS I'M I'M
TALKING ABOUT THE SMALLER ONES
NOT THE BIG -- WONDERFUL ONES
LIKE GOOD WILL -- AND URBAN
LEAGUE WHICH DO GREAT WORK WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE ONES ARE
REALLY TRYING TO GET INVOLVED IN
THE WORK FOR SYSTEM.
THAT HAVE THE BEST CONNECTIONS
TO THE COMMUNITIES THAT WERE
TRYING TO IMPACT -- THEY ARE AS
A SAID THE CBO'S HAVE A HARD
TIME OF OF ENGAGING WITH
COMMITTEE WORTH I'M SORRY WITH
WORK FOR SOME OF WAS LOCALLY
COMMITTEE COLLEGES TO GET THE
DOLLARS.
THE RESOURCES THEY NEED TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES TO THE
COMMITTEE -- THEIR BEST AT SO
ELEVEN ELEVEN REQUIRES A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN AT LEAST ONE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD AND
ONE COMMITTEE BASS ORGANIZATION --
IN IN THE RFA WE JUST DEVELOPED
AND IT'S GOING TO THE CLEARANCE
PROCESS WERE IDENTIFYING CBO'S
THAT OR THOSE -- SMALLER ONES
THAT ARE REALLY COMMUNITY BASED
THEIR DEEP IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
WHO KNOW BEST HOW TO REMOVE
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT FOR THE
PEOPLE WERE TRYING TO IMPACT --
SUCCESSFUL APPLICATIONS ARE
GOING TO CLEARLY IDENTIFY --
WHAT THE ROLES RESPONSIBILITIES
ARE OF THE CBO'S IN THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT -- BOARDS
I IN THE APPLICATIONS THEIR
SUCCESSFUL ARE ALSO GOING TO
REFLECT THAT IN THEIR BUDGETS --
BECAUSE THE BIG PROBLEM IS IT
ONCE -- PROPOSER DEVELOPED IN
PARTNERSHIPS ARE MADE AND THEY
COME UP TO THE STATE SOMEHOW
MAGICALLY THE THE DOLLARS TEND
NOT TO GET TO THE COMMITTEE BASS
ORGANIZATIONS.
SO WERE WERE WORKING VERY HARD
TO ENSURE THAT THE RESOURCES GO --
TO THE PARTNERS UP FOR THE WORK
THAT THEY'VE IN THERE INTENDING
TO DO THEY PROPOSED TO DO -- THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD UNDERSTAND SAID JUST AS
POPULATIONS WITH ME A LOT OF
SUPPORT WRAPAROUND SERVICES
CBO'S WHO ARE GETTING INTO THIS
WORK IN THE WAYS THAT WE'RE
HOPING.
ALSO NEED THAT KIND OF SUPPORT.
SO OUR MODEL OF GRANT MAKING IS
TO PROVIDE GENEROUS HANDS ON
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
COMMITTEE BASS ORGANIZATIONS AND
PARTNERSHIPS -- THIS IS NOT
ADMIN WORK THIS IS PROGRAM WORK --
I THINK A LOT OF FOLKS DON'T.
EXPECT THAT A MARRIAGE STAFF AT
THE STATE LEVEL GOING TO BE
DOING PROGRAM WORK THERE'S
ALWAYS HIS PERCEPTION THAT IS
ALL ADMIN AT THE STATE LEVEL.
WE ARE PROPOSING -- IN THE IN
OUR BUDGETS A CHANGE PROPOSAL TO
RE DIRECT THREE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS OF THE FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS ALLOCATED. FOR
A. B. ELEVEN ELEVEN TO SUPPORT
THE STATE WORKFORCE BOARDS WORK.
IN SUPPORTING COMMITTEE BASED
ORGANIZATION SO THAT THEIR
PROGRAMS ARE AS SUCCESSFUL AS
THEY POSSIBLY.
CAN BE.
WE'RE NOT A BIG ORGANIZATION AS
THEY WERE FORCED BOARD WERE
RELATIVELY SMALL OUTFIT THIRTY
SIX STAFF.
OUR FOCUS IS A POLICY IN
BUILDING A WORKFORCE SYSTEM.
THAT WE USE GRANT FUNDS TO TRY
NEW APPROACHES LEARN FROM THE
WORK WE DO A LOT OF OF
ASSESSMENT REPORTING INFORMATION
SHARING AMONG GRANTEES WE HAVE A
UNIQUE.
INVENTION CALLED THE COMMITTEE
PRACTICE WHERE GRANTEES GET
TOGETHER ON A REGULAR BASIS AND
THEY TALK ABOUT WHAT'S WORKING
WHAT'S NOT WORKING IT KIND OF
RAISES THE LEVEL.
OF PERFORMANCE AND WORK ACROSS
GRANTEES SO THERE'S A LOT OF
HANDS ON WORK THAT HAPPENS AT
THE STATE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD TO MAKE THIS STUFF
SUCCESSFUL -- THANK YOU
[inaudible]
FINANCE [inaudible]
NO COMMENT [inaudible]
L. L..
WE CAN CONVERSATIONS BOTH WITH
THE BOARD AND WITH WITH LEAD
STAFF ARE IT HAS BECOME CLEAR
THAT THE THE THE THE BUDGET.
PROPOSAL FOR ADDITIONAL STATE.
COSTS -- IS SOMEWHAT LARGER THAN
WE WOULD SEE IN A TYPICAL GRANT
PROGRAM RUN BY STATE DEPARTMENT
UNDER ARMS INDICATED TO US THAT.
AS AS MISTER RANEY MENTIONED
THAT MUCH OF THESE ADDITIONAL
FUNDS ARE ARE.
LARGELY PROGRAMMATIC IN NATURE
NOT NECESSARILY ADMINISTRATIVE
AND THE STRUCTURE ON THAT THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION IN THE
JANICE TOLD US THAT AN OPEN WE
CONCUR WITH THAT FOR NOW AS WE
LEARN MORE ABOUT.
ABOUT THE PROPOSAL AND AND WHAT
EXACTLY THAT ADDITIONAL
AUGMENTATION WHEN WHEN TALE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LOCAL PUBLIC COMMENT EMOTIONAL
SPEAK.
HELEN ROTH DOWDEN IT'S A SAN
FRANCISCO JEWISH VOCATIONAL
SERVICES WERE IN SUPPORT WE
THINK THIS GIVES A WHOLE NEW
OPPORTUNITY BRING DIFFERENT
GROUPS INTO.
THE MIX ON WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AND REALLY REACH INTO THE THE
POPULATION THAT'S NEEDED TO BE
SERVED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A COUPLE QUESTIONS.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN WHETHER IT'S
GRANT PROGRAM REQUIRES 22% TO BE
SPENT ON ADMINISTRATION AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WHILE OTHER
GRANT PROGRAMS TYPICALLY EXPEND
5%.
I IN IN THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FIELD -- THE THE
AVERAGE -- FOR ADMINISTRATIVE --
OVERHEAD -- MINISTRY OF COST IS
AROUND 8210% -- SO FROM THIS
THESE DOLLARS.
ABOUT 8210% IS GOING TO BE
ALLOCATED TO THAT PURPOSE TO
ADMINISTRATIVE PURPOSES.
THE BULK OF THE FUNDS 33% OF THE
THREE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS IS ACTUALLY GOING TO GO
TO PROGRAM WORK PROVIDED THROUGH
THE STATE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD STAFF.
IN THE FIELD TO SUPPORT THE
GRANTEES IN TO ENSURE SUCCESS.
HOPE I DON'T THINK YOU LOST ME
BUT HE SAID 8210% I'M SORRY THE
5210% FOR WORKFORCE YEAH IN IN
THE WORK FORCE FIELD IT IT'S
IT'S MORE AROUND 8210% FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS -- FOR FOR
HOW TO GET FROM EIGHT TO TEN TO
TWENTY TWO AB WERE ONLY GONNA
USE 8210% OF THE FUNDS OF THE
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS AT THE
STATE WORKFORCE BOARD FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE WORK -- THAT'S
THE THE ACCOUNTING THE FISCAL
THE MONITORING THAT TYPE OF
THING.
THE THE BULK OF THE MONEY TWO
THIRDS OF THE FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLAR I'M SORRY TWO THIRDS OF
THREE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS WERE PROPOSING TO TO
MOVE TO THE STATE WORKFORCE
BOARD.
THAT'S DEDICATED NOT TO ADMIN
SUPPORT BUT TAX WE PROGRAM WORK
PROGRAM UP IN THE FIELD OF
PROVIDED BY A STATE MARRIAGE
STAFF THROUGH THE STATE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD.
OKAY AND ONE OF THE MINISTRATION
NOT PROPOSED ADDITIONAL GENERAL
FUND TO SUPPORT THE BOARDS
INCREASED ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS --
SO WE WERE JUST WE WERE TRYING
TO BE CONSISTENT WITH -- FINDS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE PROVIDED
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT.
SO I CONCERNS WITH REDIRECTING A
SNIFF CAM PORTION OF THE FIFTEEN
MILLION PROVIDED.
IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET FOR THE A.
B..
YOUR COMMENT OR OKAY SORRY ABOUT
THAT -- PROVIDE IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET FOR THE AB ONE ALL.
ELEVEN ELEVEN GRANT PROGRAM I'M
RECOMMENDING THE WHOLE THIS
ISSUE OPEN IN ORDER TO HAVE
FURTHER CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
BOARD ADMINISTRATION THIS
PROPOSAL THROUGH A LITTLE BUTTON.
SERGEANT HE CALLED UP THE
NUMBERS UNTIL WE'VE TO ITEMS
LEFT IT WILL BE DONE RATHER
QUICKLY.
LET'S NOT ISSUE NUMBER -- EIGHT
CAPITA EXPENDITURE PLAN
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT TRAINING
AND APPRENTICESHIPS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
OKAY TO THE CHASE -- THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
I IS ASKING FOR A SCALING UP OF
CURRENT WORK OUT IN THE FIELD --
ONE IS -- CALLED THE HIGH ROAD
CONSTRUCTION CAREERS EXPANDING
THE CAPACITY OF EACH OF FOURTEEN
REGIONAL PARTNERSHIPS TEN
MILLION DOLLARS OVER FIVE YEARS
TO SERVE THREE THOUSAND
DISADVANTAGED WORKERS PREPARED
FOR STATE APPROVED
APPRENTICESHIP.
THE COST INCLUDES RECRUITMENT
COUNSELLING MENTORING SUPPORTS A
INCLUDING STIPENDS.
MULTI CRAFT CORE CURRICULUM
TRAINING PLACEMENT RETENTION AND
THEN SUPPORTING INTERMEDIARY
PARTNERSHIPS AMONG LOCAL
BUILDING TRADES COUNCILS A
COMMITTEE BASS ORGANIZATIONS
WORK FOR SELMA BOARDS IN
COMMITTEE COLLEGES IN SOME CASES.
THAT'S ONE PIECE OF IT THE
SECOND IS HIERO TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS -- AND THE THESE
ARE BOTH EXPANDING ON A CURRENT
WORK IN THE FIELD.
HI RETRAINING PARTNERSHIPS
EXPAND TO TWENTY EIGHT PROJECTS
FROM EIGHT CURRENTLY.
ARE IN CLIMATE IMPACTED
INDUSTRIES TEN MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR ANNUALLY FOR FIVE YEARS.
TWO THOUSAND DISADVANTAGED
WORKERS SERVED TEN NEW STATE
APPROVED APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS --
PROPOSED -- NOT IN THE
CONSTRUCTION TRADES NOTHING EVEN
RELATED TO THE CONSTRUCTION
TRADES -- THESE ARE PARTNERSHIPS
OF MANAGEMENT ORGANIZED LABOR
WORKERS COMMITTEE BASS
ORGANIZATIONS SCHOOLS --
WORKFORCE BOARDS -- AND AGAIN
THE COST INCLUDES RECRUITMENT
COUNSELLING MENTORING SUPPORTS --
STIPENDS PLACEMENT RETENTION THE
WHOLE NINE YARDS [inaudible]
FINANCE.
A COMMON L. L..
M. EARLIER THIS SPRING WE
RELEASE ANALYSIS OF THE PROPOSAL
TO USE G. R. F. FUNDS FOR FOR
THESE WORKFORCE PURPOSES AN WE
WE THE POINT OF DIFFERENTIATING.
THE TWO COMPONENTS OF THE
PROPOSALS ARE THE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS OVER FIVE YEARS FOR THE
TWO HRC SEE AN H. R. T. P.
PROGRAMS IN OUR VIEW.
THOSE TWO PROGRAMS WHICH EXIST
CURRENTLY STILL AT A SMALLER
SCALE ON OUR SERVER READY TO
MOVE FORWARD ON THE DISTINCTION
WE MADE WAS THAT THE THE
ADDITIONAL COMPONENTS OF THE
PROPOSALS FOR THE WORKER
TRANSITION.
PILOT AS WELL AS FOR THE WORK
SURROUNDING THE THE COMMISSION
ON THE FUTURE OF WORK.
ARE LESS ADVANCED IN THEIR
DEVELOPMENT -- THE BOARD
MENTIONED THAT THAT THEY KNOW IS
THAT THESE THESE IDEAS WERE
STILL SORT OF COMING TOGETHER SO
TO SPEAK -- SO THE
RECOMMENDATION WE MADE UP FOR
FOR THE SUBCOMMITTEE OF THE
LEGISLATURE ARCH IS A
POTENTIALLY TO CONSIDER.
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT
OVER THESE SORT OF SECONDARY.
ARE COMPONENTS OF THIS PROPOSAL
IT COULD BE IN LEGISLATORS
INTEREST TO PROVIDE MAYBE
FUNDING ON A ONE OR TWO YEAR
BASIS AS OPPOSED TO AN ART OR A
FIVE YEAR BASIS.
AND POTENTIALLY ESPECIALLY IN
THIS FIRST YEAR OR TWO AT A
SMALLER LESS AMOUNT -- CURRENTLY
THE WORKER TRANSITION PILOT IS
IS PROPOSED TO BE FUNDED AT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR
FIVE YEARS.
WE THINK IN THE NEXT YEAR TO AS
THAT PILOT IS GETTING STOOD UP
IF LEGISLATURE'S INTEREST IN
PURSUING THIS.
A SMALLER AMOUNT COULD BE
POSSIBLE AND WOULD ALLOW THE
LEGISLATURE TO EXPRESS A LITTLE
MORE OVERSIGHT OVER AT
DEVELOPMENT.
OKAY THANK YOU -- WHAT IS THE
THE AB THREE NINETY REPORT NOT
BEEN SUBMITTED TO THE
LEGISLATURE WAS DUE ON JANUARY
FIRST OF?
THIS YEAR.
THE IT IS ALMOST FINISHED IT IT
TURNED OUT TO BE A MUCH LARGER
PROJECT THAN WE ANTICIPATED --
WE CONTRACTED WITH UC BERKELEY
LABOR CENTER THEY'VE DONE
FANTASTIC WORK IT'S A FOUR
HUNDRED PAGE REPORT -- IT'LL BE
DONE VERY SOON IS ACTUALLY.
IN DRAFT FORM IS GOING TO THE
REVIEW PROCESS AND IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE -- AND ONCE
THAT'S FINISHED WILL SUBMIT THE
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE.
MOVE THE TURN OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE -- IT'S BEEN THERE -- FOR
I THINK TWO WEEKS.
SO WITH IT'S ALMOST THE END OF
APRIL SO ROLES IN THE MAY SO
WHAT DO YOU WHAT DO YOU ESTIMATE
ONI I I I WISH I COULD SAY I I
DON'T KNOW EXACTLY HOW LONG IT'S
GONNA TAKE TO FINISH THE REVIEW
PROCESS IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE --
BUT WE'RE WE'RE EXPECTING IT
WILL TAKE LONG.
MUCH LONGER.
LEGAL OPEN UP PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
STAGGER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS PROPOSAL DO A GREAT JOB
WITH CONNECTING WORKERS WITH
STABLE LIVING WAGE CAREERS AND
WE ARE YOUR SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ELIZABETH TO
SOMEONE YOU FOR PATIENTS SERVICE
AND WERE CURRENT H. R. T. P.
GRANTEE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT --
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS -- ON
THIS BUDGET -- BUDGET ISSUE --
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE OF THE THE
CRITICAL ROLE THAT OUR WATER AND
WASTEWATER UTILITIES WORKERS
PLAY IN SECURING AND ARE CLEAN
WATER TO OUR CITIZENS ESPECIALLY
IN COASTAL AREAS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MONICA ROTELLA AND I'M HERE WITH
US YEAH YOU WHICH TO VIEW --
EDUCATION FUNDS AND SUPPORT TO
ADVANCE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
WITH THE TRADE SEE ANY PARTY
INITIATIVES.
I'M PART OF THE PROJECT AND
PROGRAM TEAM LEADING ONE OF THE
EIGHT ARCHIE TO H. R. T. P.
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS THAT IS
TRANSFORMING LIVES.
BY ADVANCING EQUITY MOBILITY AND
JOB QUALITY FOR LOW SKILLED
HEALTHCARE WORKERS EMPLOYED IN
THE JANITOR AND FOOD SERVICES
DEPARTMENTS MOVING THEM UP TO
ENTRY LEVEL CLINICAL.
ROLES AND HEALTH CARE.
THROUGH THE H. R. TWO P. PROJECT
INITIALLY WE HAVE PREPARED
EDUCATED AND HELP WORKERS AND
ROLL INTO POST SECONDARY
TRAINING PROGRAMS WE NEED
SUSTAINABLE AND QUALITY JOBS IN
THE HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY.
MANY OF THESE WORKERS ARE
IMMIGRANTS FROM MAY HE GO NATURE
YOU'RE RUSSIA UKRAINE AND OTHER
COUNTRIES THAT ARE EXTREMELY
GRATEFUL FOR INITIATIVES SUCH AS
THIS TO HELP THEM ADVANCE.
OUR FURTHER MORE THROUGH A HIGH
ROAD PARTNERSHIPS WE HAVE
SUPPORTED GREEN EFFORTS TO
REDUCE THE CARBON FOOTPRINT.
AND THROUGH EDUCATION IS MARGO
IMPLEMENTATION INITIATIVES LED
BY FRONTLINE WORKERS AND HEALTH
CARE.
THESE INVESTMENTS ARE
TRANSFORMING LIVES AND ARE
TRANSFORMING THE STATE WE CALL
HOME THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH THEIR
BEHALF WITH THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL.
THE POLICIES AND GOALS AT THE
WORKFORCE -- DEVELOP WARS BEEN
PURSUING OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS AROUND HIGH ROAD CAREERS
IS EXACTLY THE TYPE OF POLICY
THIS LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN VOTING
OUT IN BILL FORM OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS AS WELL.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE FUND
PROGRAMS THAT REWARD -- TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS THAT LEAD TO
REWARDING REAL MIDDLE CLASS
CAREERS WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS ARE NAY
BAYARDO AS HERE YOU CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MY
NAME IS DIANE FACTOR I AM THE
DIRECTOR.
OF THE HIGH ROAD TRAINING
PARTNERSHIP WHICH IS A LABOR
MANAGEMENT PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
THE SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION LOCAL SEVEN
TWENTY ONE THE REPRESENTS
REPRESENTS PUBLIC SECTOR WORKERS
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
WHO IS THE LARGEST EMPLOYER IN
THE COUNTY WITH OVER A HUNDRED
AND TWELVE THOUSAND WORKERS WE
HAVE BUILT A REAL KIND OF A WIN
WIN PARTNERSHIP OUTSIDE OF
BARGAINING A A KIND OF
PARTNERSHIP.
THAT HAS OPENED UP AND CREATED
JOBS FOR THE PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE BEEN LEFT
OUT -- PEOPLE WHO HAVE EXTENSIVE
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT BUT HAVE
THE WILLINGNESS THE DRIVE AND
ARE READY FOR LONG TERM CAREERS
IN THE COUNTY.
IN OUR PUBLIC WORKS AT OUR
BEACHES AND HARBORS AT OUR PARKS.
IT IN OUR SUPPORT OF HOUSING
PROGRAMS IN OUR HEALTH CARE --
COMMUNITY CLINICS AND WE BELIEVE
THAT A PROGRAM LIKE THIS IS VERY --
EFFECTIVE USE OF FUNDS BECAUSE
IT ACTUALLY TRANSFORMS PEOPLE'S
LIVES AND THROUGH THIS ECONOMIC
STABILITY THEY ALSO TRANSFORM
THEIR COMMUNITIES THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR I
MEDIAN FOREMAN I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR THE HOSPITALITY
TRAINING ACADEMY WHERE THE LABOR
MANAGEMENT PARTNERSHIP FOR UNITE
HERE LOCAL LEVIN WHICH SERVES
LOS ANGELES ORANGE COUNTY IN THE
STATE OF ARIZONA.
WE'RE PROUD TO BE A RECIPIENT OF
ACCELERATOR AN H. R. T. P. FUNDS
AMONG OTHER GRANTS -- FROM THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD WE THINK IT'S
BECAUSE OF THE LEADERSHIP OF TIM
RAINY AND THAT BOARD AND THE
SUPPORT WE GET FROM THAT BOARD.
THEY WERE ABLE TO DO WHAT WE DO
WHICH IS TO MOVE LOW INCOME
FOLKS INTO THE MIDDLE CLASS
THROUGH JOBS STARTING AS
DISHWASHERS MOVING THEM UP TO
CLARK'S.
STARTING IS ROOM ATTENDANTS
MOVIE THEM UP TO FRONT DESK
CLERK ALL OF THOSE JOBS TRYING
TO MOVE PEOPLE INTO THE MIDDLE
CLASS OFF OF GOVERNMENT
ASSISTANCE.
BECAUSE OF OUR TRAINING PROGRAMS
WERE ABLE TO TEACH PEOPLE HOW TO
USE GREEN CHEMICALS HOW NOT TO
INJURE THEMSELVES HOW TO DO
SAFETY AND SANITATION HOW NOT TO
HAVE FOOD WASTE.
REALLY ARE ARE A LOT OF OUR
EFFORT IS IN THE GREEN.
FIELD IN IN THE CLEANING EFFORTS
THAT THE ROOM ATTENDANTS ARE
DOING ANY IN THE KITCHENS
KEEPING PEOPLE SAFE AND FREE OF
FOOD -- A BLOOD BORNE PATHOGENS
SO REALLY THIS PAPERWORK IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO US IT
BELONGS IN THIS TYPE OF EQUITY
IN GOOD CLIMATE JOBS.
AND SO IT REALLY IS FOR US
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA LEAD IN THIS
EFFORT AND HOPE THAT THIS.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS DANIEL TOURISM WITH
THE FLINT RIDGE CENTER IN
PASADENA WHERE ONE OF THE HIGH
ROAD CONSTRUCTION CAREERS --
TRAINING PROGRAMS.
SO OVER THE LAST ON THREE OR
FOUR YEARS.
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO WORK CLOSELY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD IN THIS TAKING
US ALL OVER CALIFORNIA
ESTABLISHING THESE HIGH ROAD
CONSTRUCTION CAREER PROGRAMS.
THAT ARE PROVIDING LIFE CHANGING
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES TO MANY
PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND AND I WANT TO GET INTO THE
GREEN TO GREEN IS SORT OF BETTER
TAKE A TIME RIGHT HERE YEAH THE
FIRST MONTH OF A QUORUM ALL DAY.
SO WE'RE GONNA TO TAKE ROLL CALL
PLEASE THEMSELVES A QUORUM.
COOPER.
HERE. TO LACKEY YES MA'AM THIS
AREA.
AND WHAT.
CIRCULAR VOTE ONLY CALENDAR --
WE'RE GONNA TAKE UP ITEMS NUMBER.
ONE IN.
THREE ROLL CALL PLEASE.
COOPER HI [inaudible]
TO LACKEY NO.
THE VARIANT WICKS.
THIS WILL TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER
TWO ON THE FOLLOWING CALENDAR
[inaudible]
COOPER HI [inaudible] TO LACKEY.
FIVE THE VARIANT.
WICKS.
MR IN THIS AREA HAS ARRIVED
[inaudible]
SURE.
SO FOR THE BILL ONLY -- ITEMS
ONE THROUGH THREE ONE IN ONE
THREE I'M SORRY -- ROLL CALL
PLEASE ADD.
TO AND IS THERE IN I VERY.
THE VOTE ONLY A NUMBER THREE
ROLL CALL PLEASE I'M SORRY ITEM
NUMBER.
TWO ADD TO THIS AREA.
THIS IS -- THE STATE CAPITAL.
A NUMBER TO THE INFORMATION
EIGHTY D. INFORMATION SECURITY
ENFORCEMENT TEAM -- I RIGHT WE
HAVE RATED ABOUT -- THIS WILL GO --
TO ON THE ACTION ITEMS ITEM
NUMBER -- ONE RECOGNITION TO
PROVE HIS BUDGET.
ALTHOUGH PLEASE COOPER HI
[inaudible] TO LACKEY I'VE
[inaudible]
THE VARIANCE [inaudible]
WICKS.
A SOLUTION NUMBER TWO AND THE
RECOGNITIONS PROVIDE FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND.
TO CREATE THE DOMESTIC WORKERS
RIGHT EDUCATION AND OUTREACH
PROGRAM THE CALIFORNIA VISION
LABOR STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT.
ADULT PLACE ALL THE TROUBLING
WAS TO IMPLEMENT THE GRANT
PROGRAM.
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
COOPER HI.
TO LACKEY HI.
THE VARIANCE
.
SORRY ABOUT THAT SIR YOU'RE FREE
TO CONTINUE.
THANK YOU WELL. TO GET TO IT OUT
OF WERE STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN ELEVEN AND THE HIGH ROAD
TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS IN HIGH
ROAD CONSTRUCTION CAREERS THANK
YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME SAY
THAT KIND OF THE LAST ON THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR BUILDING
SKILLS PARTNERSHIP PART OF THAT --
FIRST PHASE OF THAT -- EACH RTP
PROJECT TO WEAR A LABOR
MANAGEMENT PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
SEIU UNITED SERVICE WORKERS WEST
IN OVER FORTY JANITORIAL
COMPANIES AND BUILDING OWNERS AT
PARTNER TOGETHER TO LOOK AT
UPSCALING OUR INDUSTRY IN
JANITORIAL SPECIFICALLY AND WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON A GREEN
JANITOR CERTIFICATION PROGRAM
THAT WE WE ARE.
ABLE TO EXPAND STATEWIDE -- IT
DURING THIS DURING THIS LAST
CYCLE AND ALSO PILOT OTHER
PROJECTS -- TO UP SKILL -- THE
JANITORIAL INDUSTRY I'VE BEEN
WORKING THE JANITORS FOR OVER
FOR TWENTY ONE YEARS AND TWENTY
ONE YEARS AGO WERE FIGHTING IN
THE STREETS FOR DIGNITY AND
RESPECT FULL TIME WORK SICK DAYS
VACATION THE BASICS.
AND FAST FORWARD TWENTY ONE
YEARS WERE NOT PARTNERING WITH
COMMERCIAL REAL ESTATE ORDERS
LARGEST LARGE AND SMALL
JANITORIAL COMPANIES TO LOOK AT
WAYS.
ED TO PARTNER IN HIGH IN THE
HIGH ROAD -- TO LOOK AT WIN WIN
SOLUTIONS AND OPPORTUNITIES TO
UPSCALE OUR INDUSTRY TO PROVIDE
A BETTER SERVICE A BETTER
QUALITY OF SERVICE IN THE
BUILDINGS AND TO ME JANITORS NOT
JUST.
PART OF THE SALUTE PART OF THE
CONVERSATION ON A GREEN ECONOMY
BUT ALSO PART OF THE SOLUTION IN
CERTIFYING GREEN JANITORS AND A
COUPLE OF THEM WILL TEST WILL
WILL -- ARE HERE IN SUPPORT
TODAY AS WELL I SUPPORT IN
INVESTING IN THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE I SUPPORT IN UPSCALING
INDUSTRIES I SUPPORT HIGH ROAD
PARTNERSHIPS AN APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS I RECOGNIZE THE VALUE
IN INVESTING IN CALIFORNIA
WORKERS.
THANK YOU.
WHEN ASKED ME NUMBER IS NOT
ASKING ABOUT YOUR SO YOU'RE LIKE
ANYTHING GOOD ABOUT HIKING
SECOND I MADE BILL IT'LL MAYES
THAT BLASTED THE JENNY THE RIVER
THERE?
HE IS A REPORT THAT THE GOING TO
TURN THE DONE IT DOES IS TO THE
A MOST SUSPECT LASTED. FORTY CAN
ALSO THROWS ALMOST.
LESS PER SON LAST SUMMER LOS
ILLEGALS ALL CALLS.
GAY AND THE MOST AND THE LADY
FUTILITY SO.
MUM BUT HAND ONLY BE HANDLED IN
THOSE ALMOST WENT THAT ONE
THOUGH.
I YEAH WANNA I WILL NOT FORGET
THE I WHAT IS THE SELECT
PERSONAS GOOD FOR THEIR MOST.
ENGLAND THAT IS THE LAN.
LARA THE LAW IS STILL A CREDIBLE
NOTE DOWN THE MOST POINT THAT.
ONE THOUGH I IF FOUR GUYS THE I
WANT.
IT WHAT THE GLASSES.
AND I'LL BE PROVIDING THE
TRANSLATION I THIS IS DORIS OVER
SHE'S A JANITOR HERE IN
SACRAMENTO -- SHE WEEKS WORKS
FOR ABLE ON SHE ALSO
PARTICIPATED IN THE GREEN
JANITOR EDUCATION PROGRAM SHE'S
A CERTIFIED GREEN JANITOR.
AND SHE WAS EXPLAINING THE VALUE
THAT SHE SAW ON THE COURSE --
SHE'S SHE LEARNED THAT AS
JANITORS OF THE EYES AND EARS OF
THE FACILITY THAT THEY WORK IN
AND SO THEY'RE REALLY AT THE
FRONT LINES OF BEING ABLE TO
IDENTIFY -- FOR INSTANCE WATER
WASTER ENERGY WASTE IN THE
BUILDING IF THERE'S ANY KIND OF
ISSUE LIKE THAT -- REALLY
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT WILL BE
ABLE TO IDENTIFY THAT AND MAKING --
YOU KNOW THAT THE ENVIRONMENT
FOR ALL OF US CLEANER AND SAFER.
THANK YOU THINK.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME SOPHOMORE
FROM GULLO I WORK AT ABLE
BUILDING SERVICES AND THE
BUILDING HERE CASTRATION
SACRAMENTO AND I TOOK THIS CLASS
PROGRAM BY MENTAL.
AND I SEE THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD
THINGS INTO IT IN BECAUSE AS YOU
MENTIONED ARE JUST NOW WE ARE
THE EYES AND EARS OF THE
BUILDING.
AND WE SEE WHAT THE CHEMICALS WE
USE IN THE ENVIRONMENT WE THE
AIR WE BREATHE INSIDE THE
BUILDING AND OUTSIDE AND I WILL.
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANKS VERY
MUCH YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M JIM PARTRIDGE
ON WITH THE PROPOSITION THIRTY
NINE CITIZENS OVERSIGHT BOARD.
BEARDED BUT TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
WHICH UNDER PROPOSITION THIRTY
NINE DEVELOP SUCCESSFUL PILOT
PRE APPRENTICESHIP TRAINING
PROGRAM FOR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES THAT TRAIN
DISADVANTAGED INDIVIDUALS.
IN JOBS RELATED TO ENERGY
RETROFITS IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
THE OVERSIGHT BOARD'S RECENT
ANNUAL REPORTS LEGISLATURE
CONTAIN THE FOLLOWING
RECOMMENDATION PROVIDE DIRECT
SUPPORT TO THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S PRE
APPRENTICESHIP TRAINING PILOT
PROGRAM.
THIS PROGRAM IS A CLEAR WINNER
WORKING WITH JUST THREE MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR TO SHOW TRULY
IMPRESSIVE JOB RESULTS.
AND PLACEMENT RESULTS FOR
DISADVANTAGED JOBSEEKERS
INCLUDING HARD TO PLACE WORKERS
SUCH AS VETERANS.
AT RISK.
YOUTH WOMEN VETERANS AND
FORMERLY INCARCERATED AND
INDIVIDUALS.
OVER THE COURSE OF THE
PROPOSITION THIRTY NINE PROGRAM
THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD'S INVEST A TOTAL OF
THIRTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS TO DEVELOP TWELVE
PERHAPS PRINTS SHIP PARTNERSHIPPROGRAMS.
AND THESE TRAINING PILOTS
PROVIDED CLEAN ENERGY JOB SKILLS
FOR MORE THAN FOURTEEN HUNDRED
DISADVANTAGED INDIVIDUALS.
THIS PRIEST APPRENTICESHIP
TRAINING PROGRAM IS THE PIECE OF
THE CLEAN ENERGY JOBS ACT MOST
CONSISTENTLY LOOKED AT AS A
MODEL FOR OTHER STATES.
AND THE CITIZENS OVERSIGHT BOARD
STRONGLY BELIEVE THE CONTINUED
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM.
AT A MINIMUM OF AT LEAST THREE
MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR
POTENTIALLY FROM CAP AND TRADE
REVENUES IS WORTHWHILE.
WE BELIEVE CONTINUED SUPPORT AND
EXPANSION OF PRE APPRENTICESHIP
TRAINING PROGRAMS.
WILL CREATE ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR DISADVANTAGED
CALIFORNIANS AND ACHIEVE EVEN
GREATER RESULTS IN THE FUTURE
THANK YOU.
HELLO THOUSAND SEIU LOCAL ONE
THOUSAND THE STATE WORKERS WERE
IN SUPPORT OF THESE NEW
INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
LUCINDA ONE WOULD BELIEVE CHILLS
PARTNERSHIP WHERE GRANTEE I URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL OR THIS
YOU KNOW THIS PROPOSAL -- WE
HAVE TRAINED THUS FAR CLOSE TO
SOME HER DAHLE OR SOONER WORKERS
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BUT THE STATE
INCLUDING THE EXPANSION THE
PROGRAM INCLUDING DEVELOPING
CAREER PATHWAYS PROGRAM.
SURGEON TO INVEST [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- I'VE CONCERNS WITH
REDIRECTING SIGNIFICANT PORTION
OF THE FIFTEEN MILLION PROVIDE
IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET FOR THE AB
ELEVEN ELEVEN GRANT PROGRAM.
I RECOMMEND WE HOLD THIS ISSUE
OPEN IN ORDER FOR THAT FOR THE
CONVERSATIONS.
WITH THE BOARD ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSAL SOLD OPEN.
I CAN ASSURE NEXT MOVES ARE LAST
ITEM.
WHOOPS.
LARA ONE ON THAT I'M SORRY
[inaudible]
HOLD OPEN [inaudible]
FROM THE OKAY.
WHEN I SAW HIM AS THE -- OVERALL
BUDGET.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR JOSH
WILL GO OKAY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
RELATIONS BOARD -- THANKS FOR
TIME THIS AFTERNOON OF THE STAFF
TO THROW RIGHT UP ON OUR BUDGET
SITUATION.
AS I WILL GO TOO MUCH INTO
DETAIL I WILL SAY THAT THE
INVESTMENTS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
IS MADE.
OVER THE LAST BUDGET -- SEVERAL
BUDGET CYCLES HAS READ SALTED
AND A DECREASE IN PROCESSING
TIME.
A DECREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
AVERAGE OPEN CASES IN INCREASE
IN THE NUMBER OF EARLY
SETTLEMENTS ARE PROCESS A
DECREASETHE NUMBER OF APPEALS
THAT HAD TO OUR BOARD.
AND AT THE BOARD LEVEL ITSELF WE
THE BOARD HAS DONE A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF WORK OF THE LAST YEAR
LOWERING ITS DOCKET FROM WELL
OVER EIGHTY CASES. TO ONLY FORTY
FIVE AS OF TODAY.
IN THIS LAST BUDGET YEAR THEY'VE
ALREADY ISSUED SEVENTY SIX
DECISIONS COMPARED TO ONLY SIXTY
ONE THE PREVIOUS FISCAL YEAR
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GREG
CRITICAL WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL AND
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT AT
THIS TIME WE WOULD BE OPPOSED TO
THE THE PREPARATION OF TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OF
ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
AS REQUESTED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ -- GIVEN THE
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE OF
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS AND FUNDING
PURPOSES RECEIVED OVER THE LAST
YEAR -- TO ADDRESS PURPOSE
BACKLOGS IN CASELOAD WE BELIEVE
IT WOULD BE PRUDENT TO ALLOW
THOSE RESOURCES TO BE FULLY
IMPLEMENTED BEFORE WE BEGIN
EXPLORING ADDITIONAL
APPROPRIATION AUTHORITY -- IN
ADDITION PURPOSE STILL
IMPLEMENTING A NUMBER OF
ADMINISTRATIVE AND TECHNOLOGICAL
SOLUTIONS THROUGH ITS CASE
PROCESSING INITIATIVE.
WHICH WILL PROVIDE FURTHER
EFFICIENCY.
WE WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THAT THE
NUMBER OF CASES FILED IN BEING
PROCESSED OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS HAS REMAINED RELATIVELY.
FLAT OR EVEN WHILE PURPOSE
CONTINUE TO RECEIVE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES.
THEREFORE WE'RE CAN UP CONCERNED
ABOUT PROVIDING THIS LEVEL OF
APPROPRIATIONS OR AUGMENTATION
WHICH REPRESENTS A 17% INCREASE
TO PURPOSE OVERALL BUDGET
WITHOUT SPECIFICALLY
UNDERSTANDING WHERE THAT FUNDING
WILL BE APPLIED.
WHAT CAN BE EXPECTED WITH SUCH A
LARGE INCREASE AND A DETAILED
PLAN OF HOW THIS FUNDING WILL BE
USED FOR THE MORE?
WITHOUT PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
POSITION AUTHORITY IT'S A IT'S
UNCLEAR HOW PER WOULD UTILIZE
THAT ADDITIONAL AUGMENTATION SO --
AT THIS TIME BASED ON THE
ADMISSION BASS REVIEW THAT WE
JUST COMPLETED.
AND THE ANALYSIS THAT WAS
CONDUCTED WE BELIEVE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL IS
SUFFICIENT TO HELP HER BELONG IN
TERMS OF THEIR CASELOAD AND
BACKLOG SITUATION.
AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
COOPERATIVELY WITH THEM TO
ADDRESS ANY FUTURE NEEDS THAT
THEY NEED TO CARRY OUT THAT
MISSION AND FUNCTIONS OF THE
BOARD.
THANK YOU SEVEN THE JOINED BY
SOMEONE WERE RODRIGUEZ WE JUST
DISCUSSING YOUR THE FUNDING --
DATA COMMENT ON IT.
NOT OR NO WORK YOU'VE BEEN SO
FAR BUT FIX.
BUT WHAT IS TO SAID THEY DON'T
BELIEVE THE MONEY'S MUSICIAN A
TWO POINT FIVE MILLION AS
NECESSARY.
WELL WITH THE ACTION COME INTO
THE END OF A SURE THAT WITH THE
COMING HOT.
COMMAND HOT I GUESS.
WELL -- I THINK IT'S OF
NECESSARY THAT THEY NEEDED AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE HERE AND
HOPEFULLY THAT THE COMMITTEE
SEES IT THAT WAY AND HOPEFULLY I
CAN -- GET YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
DIGITAL FUNNY THEY CAN DO WHAT
THEY NEED TO BE DONE
[inaudible]
L. L. -- QUESTION THIS PER
BELIEVE THAT THE TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS
NECESSARY.
AND WHAT WOULD THIS BE USED.
FOR UP MISTER CHAIR WE
APPRECIATE THE RESOURCES THAT
WE'VE BEEN GIVEN OVER THE
PREVIOUS YEAR I CANNOT THINK OF
A STATE AGENCY OR BOARD THAT
WOULDN'T.
LIKE TO HAVE OF MORE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR WHAT -- FOR THE JOB
THAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
DOING -- WE DO HAVE A NUMBER OF
IDEAS OF THINGS THAT COULD BE
USED AND WE LOOK FOR TO WORKING
WITH FINANCE AND THE LEGISLATURE
TO DETERMINE WHAT'S AN
APPROPRIATE AMOUNT -- TO FUND
OUR OPERATIONS.
IT QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
ALTHOUGH NO FOR A PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MITCH
SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL WITH
THE NUMBERS ARE PRETTY CLEAR
THAT -- PUBLIC SECTOR WORKERS
ARE FACING A REAL CRISIS IN
MAKING SURE THAT THESE CLAIMS
ARE TAKEN CARE OF IN A TIMELY
MANNER.
THE LONGER IT TAKES THE MORE
LIKELY THE WORKERS ARE TO GO
AWAY THE LESS LIKELY THE
EMPLOYERS ARE TO FACE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THIS SORT OF
THING.
AND WE JUST DON'T THINK THAT'S
THE WAY THE SYSTEM SHOULD WORK
AND SO WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MICHELLE CAST OF THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION --
WE TO SUPPORT THIS REQUEST -- AS
MR SECKER MENTIONED --
EXPEDIENCY IS WHAT'S KEY AND
RESOLVING ISSUES FOR AGGRIEVED
PARTIES -- WELL.
HAS MADE SOME PROGRESS ON THE
PROCESSING OF CASES THE
LEGISLATURE OF THE LAST FEW
YEARS HAVE PUT ADDITIONAL
RESPONSIBILITIES AND DUTIES ON
PURPOSE.
THAT WILL IN THE FUTURE AS THOSE
LAWS BECOME IMPLEMENTED DELAYED --
ACTION EVEN FURTHER SO WE ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BELABOR THE
POINT OUR BRAIN ALSO WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES WERE
ALSO STRONG SUPPORT -- WE FOR
THE REASONS PREVIOUSLY STATED BY
OUR FRIENDS AT THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATIONS -- THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION --
WE BELIEVE THIS APPROVED
INVESTMENT -- SO RELATIVELY
SMALL INVESTMENT -- MAY TO
ENSURE THAT OF THEIR CRITICAL
AGENCIES WORKING EFFECTIVELY AND
EDUCATING CLAIMS ON BEHALF OF
BOTH WORKERS AND OF THE
EMPLOYERS -- OF OF THOSE WORKERS
SO.
WE THINK THIS APPROVED
INVESTMENT WOULD -- RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST FOR THIS COMMITTEE AND
THE LARGER BUDGET -- COMMITTEE
TO APPROVE THIS REQUEST THANK
YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CHRISTY VELMA WE HAVE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THIS REQUEST.
I WOULD NOTE THAT IN TRACKING
THE CASE PROCESSING EFFICIENCIES
INITIATIVE THAT THE BOARD UNDER
TOOK OVER THE LAST EIGHTEEN
MONTHS.
SEVERAL OF THE MOST SUBSTANTIVE
IDEAS ALL RIGHT IN A FIGHT IS
NEEDING AN INCREASED FUNDING TO
IMPLEMENT SO I'VE.
I WELCOME THE DIRECTORS
BRAINSTORMING AND HOPEFULLY
YOU'LL PROVE THIS APPROPRIATION
THANK YOU. FOR THE WHOLE THIS
ITEM OPEN IN ORDER TO TAKE A
CLOSE LOOK AT THE BUDGET REQUEST.
SO HOLD OPEN.
THANK YOU.
WE DO HAVE ONE LAST ITEM BEFORE
THAT ONLY GO IN THAT MISTER
[inaudible]
TO OKAY.
SO GO BACK TO OUR VOTE ONLY
COUNTER -- ON ITEMS ONE IN.
THREE ROLL CALL PLEASE.
TWO FIVE ON ITEM TO ROLL CALL
PLEASE [inaudible] TWO NUMBER
THAT ARE ACTION ITEMS -- ISSUE
NUMBER -- ONE WORKPLACE CONDUCT
THE PREVIOUS BUDGET ROLL CALL
PLEASE CHAU.
ITEM NUMBER -- TWO PROVIDE FIVE
MILLION IN ONE TIME GRANT IN ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND TO CREATE THE
DOMESTIC WORKERS RIGHTS
EDUCATION NOW WHICH PROGRAM WITH
THE CALIFORNIA VISION OF LABOR
STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT.
ALSO DOT PLACE OF THE TRUE THE
BILL LANGUAGE TO IMPLEMENT THE
GRANT PROGRAM.
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
TWO I DO BELIEVE THAT'S THE THE
VOLUME.
THE USER.
TO EARLIER I WAS REMISS IN
MISSION EVER GONNA PULL ITEM
NUMBER.
FOUR AND NOT VOTE ON AND JUST
HAVE A OF A HEARING ON IT ONLY.
TAKE THAT UP RIGHT NOW.
AND THAT'S ISSUE OVER FOR A LRB
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CHRISTINE RODRIGUEZ I'M THAT
CHIEF ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER AT
THE AGRICULTURAL LABOR RELATIONS
BOARD BEFORE YOU TODAY WE HAVE
TO BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS.
I'LL START WITH THE FIRST ONE
WHICH IS FOR THE OFFICE OF THE
BOARD THIS IS NOT A NEW PROPOSAL
IT'S BEEN BEFORE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ON SEVERAL
OCCASIONS.
THIS IS TO REQUEST.
AS PERMANENT FUNDING FOR TWO
POINT FIVE POSITIONS IT'S A
CREATES TO ONE ATTORNEY FOR AND
ONE AND A HALF.
ADMIN A HEARING OFFICER'S WHICH
ARE MINISTRY OF LODGES.
YOUR TO THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
THESE POSITIONS IN THE FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN BUDGET ACT IT WAS TAKING
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED TO SIX
HUNDRED DAYS TO CONDUCT THE
HEARINGS.
WITH THE ADDITIONAL POSITIONS WE
HAVE BEEN CONSISTENT WITH THE
INITIAL HEARINGS BEEN SCHEDULED
WITHIN SIXTY TO NINETY DAYS AND
ENSURES THAT WE HAVE CONTINUITY
IN OUR CASE LITIGATION.
WITHOUT THE WITHOUT THE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES IN OUR
HEARING OFFICER POSITIONS THAT
WOULD LEAVE US WITH A ONE POINT.
FIVE JUDGES.
WHICH WOULD CONSERVATIVES
SERIOUSLY COMPROMISE THAT
EFFECTIVE IN TIMELY ADJUDICATION
OF CASES.
SCHEDULING OF HEARINGS AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE ALLOWS THE PARTIES
TO BE ABLE TO PRESENT THEIR
CASES RECEIVE A DETERMINATION
AND ANY REMEDIES TIMELY
INEFFICIENCY ALL IN SUPPORT OF
THE AGRICULTURAL LABOR RELATIONS
ACT.
I LOOK FORWARD TO ANSWERING YOUR
QUESTIONS ON THIS PROPOSAL THANK
YOU FINANCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GREGOR
TOLD THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
WE SUPPORT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL AND WOULD ALSO NOTE
THAT -- AS PART OF THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE.
THE DEPARTMENT OR THE BOARD WAS
REQUIRED TO SUBMIT A WORKLOAD
REPORT ANALYSIS TO THE JAIL BC
WHICH WAS SUBMITTED IN JANUARY.
WHICH WE FEEL -- FULLY DETAILS
OUT THE CONTINUED INCREASED
WORKLOAD THAT THE BOARD IS
EXPERIENCING AND JUSTIFIES THE
NEED FOR THESE.
POSITIONS AND FUNDING TO BE ON
GOING AND PERMANENT THANK YOU
THANK YOU L. L. [inaudible]
COMMENT.
OKAY A QUICK QUESTION TO THE
BOARD INTO SPACE HEARING WORK
LUGGAGE.
IF INTERESTED HEARING WORK WILL
TO CHANGE.
WE WE ANTICIPATE THE HEARING
RECORD TO CONTINUE ON THE COURSE
THAT IT HAS BEEN OVER THE LAST
THREE TO FIVE YEARS WE CURRENTLY
HAVE EIGHTEEN CASES IN A JUDGES
Q..
AND THEIR IN VARIOUS PHASES WE
ARE ON TARGET WE HAD TO HEARINGS
ALREADY THIS YEAR WITH THREE
SCHEDULED FOR THE REMAINDER OF
THE FISCAL YEAR.
WHICH BUDGETS ON TARGET FOR
AVERAGE OF FIVE CASES -- ON A
YEAR.
WHAT IS A BOARD NEED TO CONVERT
THE LIMITED TERM POSITIONS TO
PERMANENT POSITIONS?
WHY DO WE NEED TO CONVERT THE
LIMITED TERM POSITIONS TO
PERMANENT POSITIONS CORRECT IT
ALLOWS CONTINUITY IN THE --
ORGANIZATION IT ALSO ALLOWS --
HIRING STAFF THAT CAN MAINTAIN --
PERMANENT STATUS IN THEIR
CLASSIFICATIONS IT PREVENTS THAT
THAT TURN OVER EVERY TWO YEARS
BECAUSE OF THE LIMITED TERM
NATURE OF THE POSITIONS.
OKAY THIS RECEIVE WITH
OPPOSITION ON THESE PROPOSALS
WERE ALL THIS ITEM OPEN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND THAT
BRINGS US TO THE FOR HEARING